. Musik Musik Musik
Musik
Dankeschön, guten Abend!
Was geht Köln?
Schönen guten Tag, schönen guten Abend.
Danke schön.
Hey, hallo!
Wuhu!
Danke schön, vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Wir können nicht zwei Gäste machen.
Ich mach Runde.
Yeah! Ich mach runter. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, Köln! Wie geht's euch Köln? Alles gut bei euch! Herzlich willkommen im Gloria-Telefon. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen bei der ersten, erst mal nur Köln und Berlin Tour 2018. Richtig, zweite Ausgabe der ersten Tour. Es ist immer noch cool. Es ist immer noch cool? Ich kann immer noch sagen, wir haben die am Anfang irgendwann mal live gesehen. Das glaube ich, das kann ich noch sagen. Ja, in gewisser Weise. Ah, fantastisch. So sieht ein Podcast-Ufoproblem aus in Köln. In Berlin war es weird. Berlin war sehr unangenehm, ja, sehr unangenehmes Publikum. Ich habe eben gerade einen Tweet gelesen, dass die meisten so aussehen wie ich. Gleiche Brille, gleiche Haare, Podcast-Ufo-Merch. So dass Stefan diese Starter-Kit haben sie sich gekauft. Erklärt auch die 200 geparkten Boosted Boards vom Glorie. Das erklärt einiges. Und die ganzen Läden mit weirdem Zeug, alles leer gekauft im Umkreis. Ja, ganz geil.
Ja, stimmt schon. Stefan hat drei Kaffees getrunken, bevor wir... Ja, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt. Deswegen bin ich in der Kaffee. Ja, es wäre in der Probe zweimal von der Bühne gefallen. Also ich würde die ersten, sagen wir mal so acht Reihen bitten. Es ist ja immer, es ist ja schwer abzuschätzen, wie weit hohe Dinge... Vor allem, man muss auch mal sagen, in der Probe, da waren die ganzen Stühle noch nicht hier, und ich dachte, wir haben nicht bestuhlt. Es ist einfach nicht bestuhlt, wir haben einfach ein stehendes Publikum, was so die Greatest Hits mitsingt die ganze Zeit und so mitklatscht, so wie so eine schlechte Band. Wir machen trotzdem eine Wall of Death, also macht euch da keine Sorgen. Ja genau. Das wird noch kommen, da müsst ihr dann aufstehen. Gab es das jemals, eine Comedy-Show mit einer of Death? Ich weiß nicht, glaube ich. Warum nicht? Aber auch dieses Am-Roden-Legen, warst du mal bei so einem Freiluftkino, wo man dann so auf der Wiese liegt? Von Wall of Death kommst du auf Freiluftkino? Was siehst du da für Filme? Siehst du so Indie-Filme, wo man durch so ein Rapsfeld läuft und so. Nein, nein, nein, mir war Wacken zu anstrengend, deswegen habe ich die Live-Übertragung von Wacken auf einer Wiese mit so leider vierzigjährigen Müttern. Picknick-Pärchen und so. Nee, Picknick plus Wacken ist für mich die schönste Nachmittags-Szenen. Du Schatz, ich bin ein ganz großer Motorhead-Fan. Ja, aber ich bin auch ein Fan von so Erdbeeren mit Schokoladenüberzug und das ist einfach die Perspektive Motivation. Ja, best of both worlds. Ja, das stimmt. Ich war ja noch nie auf irgendeinem Festival, muss ich ganz... Ich habe auch gemerkt... Nee, nicht... Das sind die schlimmsten Momente im Leben, wenn man überhaupt kein Mitleid will, aber es bekommt. Aber ich habe diese World of Death nicht hundertprozentig verstanden, weil du bist ja da... Also du willst ja eine gute Zeit. Und dann tust du dir weh. Ja. Also im Kern tust du dir weh, du läufst in andere Menschen rein, warum? Du musst nicht da reinlaufen. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, ich glaube das ist einfach so, man muss sich eine Form von Tanzen überlegen. Ich glaube es ist so, jede Musikerätin hatte ihre Form zu tanzen. Der Parttanz ist ein bisschen weird bei so, bei Motorhead. Der Parttanz ist schon ziemlich, drei Jahre Flamenco-Training hat mir nichts gebracht auf Wacken, gar nichts. Aber es ist interessant, dieses Ohrgeräusch finde ich immer sehr interessant. Ich finde es immer interessant, was für Geräusche Gruppen machen können, weil es ist ja auch die kleinsten Geräusche werden ja in der Gruppe sehr gross. Können wir mal versuchen, dass das gesamte, Moment, Moment, Moment, das gesamte Publikum auf mein Kommando mit den Augen rollt. Oh ja, mich würde wirklich mal interessieren, mich würde wirklich mal interessieren, wir sind hier so acht, sieben, achttausend Leute, ab irgendeinem Punkt, oder ist es denn so, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, ist es wirklich so, dass wenn, lass es nochmal, dass wenn gleich viele können uns hier hinsetzen wenn diese stuhle stuhle wenn wir das ist unser wir haben wir haben extra diese stelle aufgebaut falls wir mal ein auto setting brauchen für für stefans geniale auto anekdoten und falls ihr einfach nicht in der lage seid ich kann es mir nicht vorsteig jetzt bitte ein sollte es einsteigen Sollte es einsteigen ins Auto. Oh, sorry, Entschuldigung. Jetzt stehe ich den anderen Autos im Weg. Entschuldigung. Komm jetzt, ich habe warmes Blinklicht an, hinter mir hüpft schon einer, jetzt steig endlich ein. Was ist das für eine Tür? Was ist das kleinste Auto der Welt? Warum bist du nicht denn? Also, worüber wollt ihr noch mal reden? Ich wollte überreden, ob es wirklich... Zum Beispiel ist es ein gutes Beispiel. Sorry, wirklich. Es ist zum Beispiel ein gutes... Ich bin so der nervige Mitfahrer, der die ganze Zeit so... Ja, der auch die ganze Zeit oben an dem Panikgriff festhält, weil er mir nicht vertraut. Ja, aber allein die Tatsache... Was soll das bringen vor allem? Außer dass, wenn dir jemand frontal reinfällt, dein Arm auf jeden Fall weg ist. Ja, das stimmt. Das sind immer so, wenn die Feuerwehr da so deine Leiche aus dem Auto schneidet, so... Alles ist komplett zermatscht, nur der rechte Arm. Ja, perfekt. Sieht perfekt aus. Der ist perfekt. Den kann sich die Familie dann die familie an die wand hängen und deswegen liebe kinder immer einen panikgriff fassen das ist ein poster wo alles voller blut ist außer dieser eine arm vor allem zum thema zum thema autosicherheit airbags geile idee aber airbags sind so ein bisschen das gegenteil von natürlicher selektion die sich da vorne links hingesetzt weil sie dachten das da vorne links hingesetzt haben. Genau so! Ihr wusstet am Anfang schon, dass wird... Ja, keine Chance. Ich wusste, das Autosetting war eine schlechte Idee. Ja, ja, ich weiss. Wir können ja noch ein Flugzeug draus machen vielleicht. Aber was ich sagen würde, Airbags sind so ein bisschen das Gegenteil von natürlicher Selektion, weil es beschützt alle, aber bestraft Kleinkinder. So ein bisschen so, wir haben hier diese Technologie, die ist perfekt für 85% der Bevölkerung. So 14-Jährige überleben jeden Crash, 17-Jährige überleben jeden Crash, Kleinkinder tot, sofort tot. Beim Kleinst mit 30 kmh gegen so die Leitplankige Dots Kind tot. So, vorne. In jedem Auto ist mittlerweile diese kleine Zeichnung, dass man die Kindersitze nicht falsch herum, ne, nur falsch herum?
Ich wollte mich gerade über die Leute lustig machen, die dieses Zeichen noch brauchen und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man es hinstellen muss.
Leute, im Zweifel seitlich, im Zweifel seitlich.
Ganz kurz, ohne dass jemand die Lösung reinruft, ganz kurz, wer glaubt, dass man es falsch herum, also dass das Kind nach hinten gucken muss? Bitte jetzt aufzeigen. Wer glaubt, dass das Kind nach vorne gucken muss? Ihr Vollidioten, ey, ihr dämlichen Vollidioten. Ich weiß nicht. Wie viele im Raum haben ihr Kind verloren? Ganz kurz mal. Ich habe die Schnittmenge. Alle in der letzten Reihe, alle, die gesamte letzte Reihe hat ihre Kinder verloren, sorry, das ist interessante Bestuhlung, es ist zu mir leid. Du wolltest über Erbeck sprechen. Ach, das hast du schon. Ich hab schon über Erbeck gesprochen, ja im Grunde. Ne, was ich sagen wollte, ist, wir haben unser Publikum noch nicht richtig konditioniert, lass uns das mal probieren mit dem Augenrollen, weil ich glaube, ist es denn wirklich so, worauf ich gekommen bin, sorry, ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt, bei Autorennen ist es doch so, dass das hintere Auto fährt und das vordere Auto anschiebt. Ich weiß nicht, von welchem Autorennen du sprichst. Fährt das vordere Auto schneller, wenn du vom Film Cars sprichst. Das ist nicht echt, das ist ein Trickfilm. Doch, doch, doch. Was für ein Autorennen meinst du? Sorry, ganz kurz, der Film Kars, wie dumm sind die denn?
Ich mein, Autos haben schon zwei Augen, die Scheinwerfer vorne, hallo, und dann macht man einen Film darüber, dass die Windschutzscheibe die Augen sind? Sorry, bin ich der einzige, dem es so geht, und der erste so, offensichtlich, Autos mit Augen, okay, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das, das ist es. Ja, vor allem das Publikum, hatten wir das ja schon mal, aber das Publikum ist ja auch komplett Autos.
Und auf so einer Tribüne, wo man sich auch fragt, wie sind die da hochgekommen und ist das nicht, ist das der beste Ort für Autos, auf einer Tribüne zu sein? Ja, das stimmt. Weil müssen dann sich Autos anschnallen? Nee, die nicht. Fährt die jemand? Nein, die fährt niemand, oder? Die haben Sitze innen drin. Massive Logiklücken in Disneys Cars. Wie sieht ein Lightning McQueen von innen aus? Also ein weirdes Gehirn und Gedärme wahrscheinlich, aber was? Das stimmt, wo ist das Gehirn? Ja, komm. Auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass wenn Auto, kann das vordere Auto anschieben, obwohl sie ja eigentlich gleich schnell fahren, das verstehe ich nicht, aber so ist es. Und genauso ist es ja auch bei geräuschen wenn ganz viele leute das gleich laute geräusch machen ist das geräusch schiebt sich amt ja lauter weil sich das anschiebt weil die die akustikwellen schieben sich so so so drücken drücken das so weg davor ich glaube ich habe gerade ein gemeinschaftliches augenrollen gehört wollen wir mal wissen, lass es mal probieren. Also jetzt mal ganz kurz.
Augenrollen.
Ich zähle bis auf die gedachte vier, alle mit den Augenrollen, aber ansonsten bitte sehr leise sein.
Was ist das nochmal ganz kurz?
Auf die gedachte vier, also nicht, dass man so eins, zwei, weiss man nicht.
Auf die null.
Nein, nein, nein, auf die gedachte vier.
Aber kommt noch eine null.
Jeder im Raum weiß, was gemeint ist, außer Stefan.
Ich bin gespannt, ich glaube, das willst du dir nicht. Also, einer... Ich weiss nichturde Stille bitte, absurde Stille. Wer hat die Lüftung an? Okay, absurde Stille, auf die gedachte vier, alle mit den Augen rollen. Drei, zwei, eins. Hä, warum lachen alle bei drei? Komisch. Hat nicht funktioniert. Der ganze Abend war nur dazu da, um dich zu pranken. Geprankt! Okay, Leute, wir kriegen das hin. Wir kriegen das hin. Auf die gedachte vier, alle mit den Augen rollen. Eins, zwei, drei. Da war ein bisschen was im Raum. Doch schon. Da war eine gewisse Energie im Raum, oder? Hast du das geschwirt? Was mich auch interessiert, wo wir gerade bei diesen lustigen Akustik-Experimenten sind. Ey, mach das den Rest des Abends, jetzt ist das scheissegal. Vergiss den Rest. Was mich interessiert, wenn ein Publikum unruhig wird, auch auf Partys, wenn man so gehen will, dann beginnt dieses über den Oberstenkel streichen, dieses langsame, und das würde ich gerne mal hören. Also über den Oberstenkel streichen, als ob man gleich gehen will und die Runde auflösen will. Einmal für Stefan bitte alle gleichzeitig über den Oberstenkel. Auf die gedachte fünf. Eins, zwei, drei, vier. Ja, man will gehen, man will gehen. Sorry, Leute, wir müssen gehen, es ist Physik.
Ich will noch einen machen, gib mir noch einen, einen einzigen will ich noch. Das Publikum ist schon unruhig. Auf die gedachte acht, einmal bitte alle durch die Haare streichen. Ja, okay, davor absolute Stille. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben und viel schöner gleich. Das für ein wunderschönes Geräusch. Das sieht besser aus. Wie so Wind, der durch so eine Wiese wandert. Aber das mache ich ja auch manchmal so im Laufe des Tages dehnt hier, als ob ich danach jemals besser aussah. Warum macht man das? Ja, stimmt. Es ist so ein Placebo-Ding einfach so ein bisschen. Es reicht. Vor allem einfach der menschliche Körper ist ja annähernd perfekt. Ich würde sagen zu 99,9 %, nur... Was ist unperfekt? Ja, das Unperfekt ist, dass die Haareare so wachsen dass man noch das braucht um perfekt auszusehen es ist schon fast da man sieht fast perfekt aus
aber man braucht noch das genau so wenn man sich die finger nähe schneiden kann hallo wie oft
scheinbar deine finger nähe ganz kurz private frage recht häufig tatsächlich sehr häufig ich
habe sehr häufig einmal die woche vor allem ich habe die feile für mich entdeckt stefan ich habe
die ich habe die feile für mich entdeckt feile vor allem, ich hab die, ich hab die Feile für mich entdeckt. Feile, vor allem Funfact, Feilen haben zwei Seiten, die grobe und die feine Seite, ja. Ich bin wirklich zwei Einstellungsstufen oder was? Zwei Seiten. Also einmal weghobeln, einmal konturen oder was? Ja, einmal grob, einmal feilen, einmal zart. Das Problem ist, man weiss nicht, was was ist und muss dann erst so drüber streichen und merkt dann selber, man hat keine Ahnung und fühlt auch nichts. Und einfach, man weiss es nicht. Aber wichtig, habe ich gelernt, aber habe ich mir das vorgestellt, dass man feilt und nicht nur die Feile bewegt, sondern auch den Finger bewegt. Einige nicken, einige nicken im Raum, die vier, die sich schon mal die Nägel gefeilt haben. Also denkt mal dran, hundertprozentig werdet ihr das nächste Mal dran denken, in den nächsten sieben Jahren, wenn ihr eure Fingernägel gefeilt. Fingern, Feile bewegen und Fingernagel bewegen, gleichzeitig. Schere oder Knipser? Schere, immer Schere. Schere. Immer Schere. Wirklich Schere? Ja, klar. Knipser ist besser. Aber der Knipser gibt halt genau die Krümmung vor, das hast du glaube ich mal. Aber du willst keine Krümmung. Sorry, wir driften ein bisschen ins Dermatologische ab. Du willst keine Krümmung. Wir können auch mal ins Auto, wir haben es für uns. Wir fahren jetzt nicht in die Apotheke und fragen Apotheker. Bitte in die Apotheke. Nein. Vor allem, du willst ja eigentlich die Fingernägel gerade geschnitten haben. Das hat mir sogar ein Arzt gesagt. Und die Frage ist, wie müssen deine Fingernägel aussehen, damit ein Arzt... Dr. Dre oder was? Macht keinen Sinn. der Gag macht keinen Sinn, es waren Tests und ihr habt gelacht und ihr seid durchgefallen. Ey, aber apropos, ganz kurz, apropos Apotheke, Leute, mir ist letztens was aufgefallen, wie unfassbar, bei Pharmakonzerne kriegen ja immer so ein bisschen schlechte Presse, so von wie, ja, die roden den Wald und die fangen den Fisch... Die machen schlechte Werbung und peinliche Zwillingswerbung und so, das will man nicht. Aber was dran geil ist, das Bayer-Logo. Seid ihr bei mir, Freunde des Podcasts? Wie unfassbar genial ist denn das Bayer-Logo? Falls ihr es nicht im Kopf habt, es ist ein Kreuz, und zwar wir lesen horizontal das Wort Bayer, B-A-Y-E-R, und wir lesen vertikal auch nochmal das Wort Bayer, B-A-Y-E-R, und das Y trifft sich in der Mitte. Wie geil ist das denn?
Weil, irgendeinem genialen Geist ist aufgefallen, pass auf.
Es ist ja das gleiche Wort, sowohl Bayer als auch Bayer haben das Y in der Mitte. Haben genau in der Mitte. Das ist nicht so trivial. Na ja, gut. Da musst du zum Beispiel mal an der Stelle, Duden ist da nicht drauf gekommen. Man könnte Duden genauso machen, die Duden völlig vollidioten. Man könnte Duden bei dem Anfangsbuchstaben ein Kreuz aus Duden machen, weil zwei Ds drin vorkommen. Jetzt wird's zu verrückt. Over your heads. Also ich möchte einfach nur sagen, Bayer, Props an Bayer, finde ich richtig gut. Gutes Logo. Einfach weil es so genial ist. Stichwort Topical Island, haben heute das Logo geändert. Wirklich? Aber es ist immer noch das Kreuz tatsächlich. Die haben nur die Farbgebung ein bisschen geändert und so ein paar die Sachen. Die dachten, dadurch fällt die ganze schlechte Presse weg. So, oh fuck, wir haben wieder Affen umgebracht. Der Artikel hieß auch, Bayer will sympathischer werden, und dann war das neues Logo, was eigentlich genauso war wie vorher, nur jetzt ist der Bayer-Schriftzug ein bisschen dunkler.
Vorher war er Silber, jetzt ist er dunkelgrau. Fand ich nicht schlecht, finde ich sympathischer, gleich sympathischer.
Nicht schlecht. Falls ihr Medikamente braucht, geht einfach am Merch-Shop vorbei, wir haben einen kleinen Bayer-Stand auch aufgebracht, kleinen Tabletten, für jeden ist was dabei. Wunderbar. Wofür müssten wir Werbung machen, dass uns niemand mehr hört, wirklich, weil dass uns alle boykottieren. Ich glaube, Big Pharma ist schon so ein Ding, oder? Nee, bei Bayer glaube ich wird niemand traurig. Ihr seid ja nicht politisch, oder? Unser Publikum ist nicht politisch. Ich weiss nicht, wo du gerade hin möchtest. Irgendwo hinin, ich weiss nicht. Das ist das Konzept des Podcasts, dass wir nicht wissen, wo wir hin wollen. Du machst eine Kiste auf, die leer ist bei mir, die völlig leer ist. Ja, ja, einmalstraße. Das ist wirklich so Nagelfallen-Anekdote, wirklich hunderte politische Meinungen. Mach zu schnell, mach so, Fledermäuse kommen raus, wie aus so alten Cartoons. Ja, ganz schlecht. Lass dich mal wechseln. Ich glaube, Telefone sind sehr unbeliebt. Ich glaube, wenn wir Werbung machen für Telefone, lass doch Leute, lass doch Telefone endlich mal aussterben, oder? Es gab doch irgendwie so einen Punkt, an dem man gesagt hat, Leute, hier Dingsfernsehen, Schwarz-Weiss-Fernsehen wird umgestellt auf Farbfernsehen, so drei, zwei, eins, jetzt ist alles in Farbe, ob ihr wollt oder nicht, jetzt ist alles in Farbe. Genauso müsste man die Telefone abschalten. Kein Mensch braucht mehr Telefone. Wie rufst du dann bei Firmen an? Du schreibst eine Mail, der schlimmste Satz, der ich finde, und ich... Oh, aus der Handynummer. Da läufst du mir jedes Mal eiskalt den Rücken runter, wenn ich folgenden Satz in einer Mail lese. Vielen Dank für Ihre Mail. Rufen Sie mich doch einfach... Nein! Das ist das Schlimmste. Das ist der Grund, warum man die Mail schreibt. Ja, vor allem das ist so, ich habe eine Mail hingeschrieben und jetzt sagen sie, er ruft doch an. Aber ich sage so, ich habe doch schon gezeigt, dass ich da keinen Bock drauf habe. Der schlimmste Satz... Aber noch schlimmer ist, wenn du eine Mail verschickst und dann dein Handy klingelt, weil du weißt, wer es war und du willst es auch nicht so richtig. Aber es ist immer besser angerufen zu werden, oder? Besser angerufen zu werden. Nee, besser anzurufen. Was? Klar, aber wir können die Umfrage machen. Ist es besser, angerufen zu werden? Ganz kurz, jeder, der dafür ist, rollt mit den Augen. Jeder, der dagegen ist, streicht sich durch die Haare. Drei, zwei, eins. Na, haben wir es auch. Demokratie funktioniert, meine Damen und Herren. Kein Ablodit für Demokratie, okay. Das ist eine interessante Entwicklung. Niemand will Demokratie. Ich glaube, da läuft einiges falsch in der Politik, oder? Findest du nicht, wenn die Leute keinen Bock mehr auf Demokratie haben? Stefan, da müssen wir ein paar Sachen ansprechen. Du hast völlig recht. Zum Beispiel die Top-5-Staatsformen, die besser sind als Demokratie. Eine Top-5-Liste, die nur falsch laufen kann. Wir greifen sehr tief in die leere Kiste rein. Platz Nummer 5, was zur Hölle auch immer Hunger Games ist. Einfach dieses, wir teilen alles auf in Distrikte. Es gibt jetzt die reichen Distrikte und die armen Distrikte. Okay. Irgendjemand hat das ja mal vorgeschlagen. Pass auf, erst mal dieses brennende Kleid durchgewunken durchs Parlament und dann gesagt, pass auf, wir teilen jetzt alles ein, ihr seid reich, wir sind arm und alle so, okay. Gut. Und es war so ein bisschen wie ein, zwei oder drei, ob ihr wirklich richtig steht, wer meint es dringt. Aber ist Olympia nicht ein bisschen wie Hunger Games, nur ohne Steaks? Ohne Steaks? Ohne Steaks. S-T-A-K-E-S-Steaks. Weil du hast, also im Prinzip treten auch Länder gegeneinander an und so und irgendwie hofft man, dass sein Land ein paar Medaillen gewinnt, aber es ist nicht so, dass man da mehr Rationen bekommt oder sowas. Wenn die Folgen ist ein bisschen wie Hunger Games nur ohne, nein, niemand, alle schütteln den Kopf. So klang das übrigens, wenn alle Leute gleichzeitig mit dem Kopf schütteln. Hatten die wirklich so viel Hunger? Also ich hatte nie das Gefühl, bei Hunger Games, ich habe, sorry, ich habe alle vier Filme geschaut und ich habe kein einziges Magenknurren gehört, ich habe kein einziges Oh, jetzt so eine Bifi oder so, einfach irgendwie so, dass man so zumindest das Gefühl hat, da hätten Leute Hunger. Nichts, gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Ist dir aufgefallen, dass wir heute keine Handtücher haben? Wir haben keine Handtücher mehr. Wir haben einen Auftritt gehabt bislang in Berlin und da hatten wir Handtücher und ich weiss nicht, wie man ohne Handtücher so einen Auftrag abend überleben soll. Wie kommen wir da durch? Ab jetzt ist es ein Blindflug einfach.
Wir können nicht gleichzeitig trinken.
Das stimmt.
Wir brauchen keine Handtücher.
Ich habe eine neue Sendung für mich entdeckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt.
Die ist schon ein bisschen länger, die ist schon ein bisschen älter,
aber ich habe die jetzt erst für mich entdeckt. Die heißt Pen and Teller Fool Us. Kennt ihr die? Kennt irgendwer neue Sendung für mich entdeckt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt, die ist schon ein bisschen länger, die ist schon ein bisschen älter, aber ich habe die jetzt erst für mich entdeckt, die heisst Pan and Teller Foolers, kennt ihr die, kennt irgendwer diese Sendung?
Ja, es ist die fantastische Sendung, ich weiß nicht.
Ich war es in 2008 auch schon gelebt, dann solltet ihr diese Sendung.
Kenntest du die Sendung?
Klar.
Es ist, ganz kurz, es ist eine Zauber-Show, eine fantastische Zauber-Show, gibt es bei Netflix, von dem Zauberer-Duo Pan and Teller, die augenscheinlichlich Riesen-Act sind, in Vegas immer ausverkaufen und so ein Kram. Und die haben jetzt eine Serie und ich finde das Konzept ein bisschen weird, weil es geht darum, dass Zauber-Acts Newcomer auf die Bühne kommen, ihren Zauber-Act machen und Penn & Teller reinlegen müssen. Das heißt, wenn Penn & Teller nicht wissen, wie sie es gemacht haben, fliegen die mit denen nach Vegas und machen eine Show. Wenn Penn & Teller herausfinden, wie der Trick funktioniert, dann haben die nichts gewonnen. So, jetzt ist aber das Prinzip, die haben sich jetzt überlegt, okay, wir lösen aber nie auf, weil wir wollen ja den Trick auch von den Leuten, von denen wir herausfinden, wie wir es gemacht haben, nicht verraten. Was dann zu dieser, wo ich denke, es ist ein komisches Konzept, weil es kommt ein Zauberer auf die bühne macht einen trick die beiden sagen ja aber und dann wollen sie dann wollen sie halt so bisschen bisschen dechiffrieren und nicht genau chifrieren und nicht genau sagen wie sie es wie das gemacht hat weil die nicht bloßstellen wollen und sagen sowas wie naja aber als die als die frau durchgesägt hast da war ein bisschen was nicht so koscher und dann sagen die ja Ja stimmt, dann wird ein Applaus und die werden rausbegleitet. Und man fragt sich so, was war das gerade? Ich bin immer noch amazed, dass die Frau noch lebt. Wieso gehen die jetzt einfach? Das ist so weirdes Konzept. Und einer von den Zauberern hat das Gimmick, dass er nicht spricht. Also es ist einfach die weirdeste Show der Welt. Aber die ist unglaublich geil. Wer ist nicht ganz verstanden, das sind zwei Leute, Penn and Teller. Penn and Teller. Es ist nicht Penn and Teller, sondern es ist ein und zwei verschiedene Leute. Der eine ist dick, der andere spricht nicht. So das ist so ein bisschen... Aber der macht ein duweides Konzept. Die Welt ist so einfach in Magie. Und dann gab es einen grandiosen Act, der war so ein bisschen wie im Film Prestige. Und zwar waren dann vorne auf der Bühne zwei Leute und dann wird plötzlich eine
eine Truhe aufgemacht, wo einer von den beiden reinsteigt, dann machen die die Truhe zu und dann machen sie die
wieder auf, eine Frau kommt raus und der Typ, der gerade noch auf der Bühne war, kommt plötzlich hinten aus den Zuschauer
rein, durchgelaufen. Und dann sagt Penn, dann sagt Penn oder Teller, ich weiss nicht, wer von beiden, der spricht,
sagt dann sowas wie, um das dann aufzulösen, ja also mega Trick, aber wenn wir beide das machen würden, würden wir das auch hinbekommen, wie ihr das gemacht habt und das Publikum klatscht und die Leute gehen wieder. Und der Zauberer so, verdammt nochmal, wie macht ihr das nur? Und man sitzt zu Hause so, was, was ist gerade passiert?
Ich war noch nie so, es war eine antiklimatische Sendung.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich, er meint damit, dass das ein Zwilling war, der Typ.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt aufstehen. Aber er meinte ja noch, wenn er dieses Geheimnis bewahrt, dann wird er irgendwann der beste Act der Welt. Das fand ich fantastisch. Wahrscheinlich sind das Zwillinge. Warum ihr? Einer von den beiden gibt es immer den Applaus, der andere nicht. Krass, aber als Zwilling hat man, ich glaube, man hat so grossen Druck als Zwilling, weil man sich immer denkt, man muss irgendwas grosses machen, weil man will ja die Chance nicht ungenutzt lassen. Stell dir mal vor, irgendwie so am Totenbett denkt er sich, ah fuck, wir hätten auch so einen geilen Zaubertrick machen können, wo er dann so von hinten und dann so, sorry, ciao, jetzt ist es auch schon egal. So, man muss das irgendwie ausnutzen oder irgendwie dann so Foto, vor allem Face Swap oder halt was anderes, so mit diesen Panda-Bären-Ohren. Ja, weil es zwei Sinn, hallo? Ja, alle verstehen nicht. Aber auch so ein Deutscher war dann da und er hat dann ein Foto gemacht von Leuten im Publikum auf seinem iPad und hat dann einen Foto-Rahmen da gehabt und hat dann so eine Fischgeste gemacht und das Foto, was er auf seinem iPad gemacht hat, hat sich plötzlich im Bilderrahmen gebildet. Aus dem Nichts. Und Penn und Teller wussten, wie er es gemacht hat und die sind mit Applaus von der Bühne gegangen. Und da denkt man, das darf nicht, aber fucking ernst sein. Und Penn und Teller meint so, mit deinem iPad war da was nicht ganz normal. Ihr habt mich hinters Licht geführt. Schau, das war's von mir. Ihr seid Genies, Mann, ihr habt's einfach. Pan and Timmer! War da etwa Magie am Werk? Ja, ihr habt recht, sorry. Fantastische Sendung, wirklich. Ich glaube, Harry Potter, wenn es die wirklich gäbe, das wäre doch deren Leben, oder? Die würden doch das machen. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Harry Potter, die würden nicht jetzt in ihrem Schloss. Alter, gibt's Zaue? Es gibt doch mehr als die Winkelgasse. Man will denen doch mal zurufen, hey Harry, es gibt mehr als die Winkelgasse und Gringotts. Gibt's eigentlich so Zauberkünstler in Harry Potter, die dann so einen Hase verschwinden lassen? Und alle so, ja, kann ich auch. Wow. Kenn ich schon, kann ich sogar. Das nervigste da. Buchseite 28. Levinus A. Danke. Danke. Das ist echt ein Problem, ne? Das ist ein Problem. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie so ein talentierter Zauberer bist, so bis elf hast du dein Leben lang nur gezaubert zu Zaubertricks, dann gehst du nach Hogwarts, alles war umsonst. Ich glaube, der Kindheit war umsonst. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Wohingegen, wenn du bis dahin schon gerne auf Besen saßt, perfekt, perfekt, einfach so, du sagst, passt, genau meins. Denkst du dir so, welche Art von generischer Zaubererwelt ist das hier? Gibt's auch Hexen, gibt's auch Hexen, ja es gibt Hexen, yes, alles klar, perfekt. Gibt's auch Zwerge, gibt's Zwerge? Gibt's eigentlich so ein Arschloch in Hogwarts, das Herr der Ringe gelesen hat und immer so, gibt's auch Steintrolle hier? Gibt's auch... Und er dann mega enttäuscht ist, dass da die Grenze ist. Wie, wie es gibt Steinmenschen, die unsere Schule beschützen, aber bei Olifanten hört's auf, oder was? Ja, ja. Oh, müssen wir gegen Sauron kämpfen? Alter, okay, schimm mal, schimm mal, schimm mal. Komm ein bisschen runter, okay. Es muss ja Herr der Ringe auch in der Harry Potter Welt geben eigentlich. Crossover. Gibt es auch diese riesigen Steinriesen, die es nur in der Hobbit gab und die im Buch gar nicht vorkommen? Chill, komm mal jetzt runter. Nein, es gibt keine Steinriesen. Ich finde fast das Beste an Penn & Teller, ich bin noch nicht fertig damit. Das Beste daran sind die Videos, die Zauberer vorstellen, weil es sind so schlag-dein-raab-artige Videos. Übrigens schlag-dein-raab-Videos, Vorstell-Videos von den Kandidaten. Was sind das für Menschen? Super Menschen, die und die, ja, ich spiele Volleyball und Handball und alles, was auf Ball endet, kann ich, perfekt. Und ich bin Professor und habe acht Bachelors und neun Masters. So ein bisschen ist es auch bei diesen Vorstellvideos von den Magiern mit dem Unterschied, dass manchmal die Familie befragt wird und die nicht so stolz sind. Und dann redet die Mutter, interviewt von dem Magier und die sagt so, Herr, wir sind wahnsinnig stolz auf unseren Sohn und der Vater sitzt da so neben und so.
Und dann gibt's nämlich ein Video, wo der so langsam wegdrift. So, All of Darkness, my old friend, muss man drunter legen und dann wird alles erzählt. Er hat sein Jurastudium abgebrochen, um Marger zu werden und nennt sich jetzt Illusionist. Ja, wir haben ihn Jonathan getauft, aber jetzt ist er Mr. Fantastic. Können wir abbrechen. Ja, wir sind sehr stolz auf ihn. Magier? Magier, wirklich? Magier? Zauberer, du bist ein Zauberer, du bist kein Magier, okay? Mama, wir hatten das Thema. Wie oft die ihre Bezeichnung ändern müssen, weil das eine uncool ist. Also das ist ja so, Zauberer, dann sind Zauberer uncool, dann sind es Magier, dann sind Magier uncool, dann sind es Illusionisten. Oh, jetzt Mentalisten. Dann geht's immer weiter. Mentalisten, ja. Es ist das gleiche, es ist einfach immer lame. Ach, kurze Frage zu Mentalisten. Jetzt bin ich auch ein bisschen unangenehm vom Publikum, aber...
Also das mit den Mentalisten, die dann so Leute so hypnotisieren und so. Ist das echt?
Weil, ich meine, das gibt's ja. Also es gibt ja Hypnose. Ganz kurz.
Ja.
Aber es gibt doch sowas wie... Ja, das ist schon, ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht so... Ich bin mit dem Schab, aber es gibt sowas wie, ich zähl bis drei und du wirst müde, aber es gibt sowas wie, also Hypnose, ja.
Ist das das gleiche? Das wäre schon fantastisch. Ja, ich glaube, jeder kennt den Moment, wo man in der stillen Stunde sich überlegt hat, ob es möglich ist, sich selbst einzublasen. Und auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, Applaus aus Schuld, Applaus aus schlechtem Gewissen. Aber irgendwie das logische Ende für ein Magierbitt. Ja, aber armsehlichlich. Also erstmal so, wenn man sich so seine eigene Körperform anschaut und denkt so, okay, du denkst, du hast eine Chance, aber auf der anderen Seite steht dir vor, du bist Hypnotiseur und du denkst dir so, kann ich mich auch selber hypnotisieren? Vielleicht habe ich mich schon selbst hypnotisiert und weiss... Wer schneidet eigentlich Friseuren die Haare?
Weird.
Dann stehen die vor so einem Spiegel.
Werde ich gerade müde?
Bist du?
Werde ich... Ist das jetzt Spiegel?
Geht das?
Bin ich jetzt ein Huhn oder bin ich jetzt ein Mensch?
Das ist extrem, extrem verwirrend eigentlich.
Richtig verwirrend.
Vor allem, also damals, ich habe in einer Band gespielt.
Und wir hatten mal einen Keyboarder.
Und der Keyboarder, der hatte, man kann ihn am besten so charakterisieren, auf seinem Keyboard war ein Sticker.
Unter anderem von dem Papst. Moment, vom echten Papst oder vom Keyboard-Papst? Vom echten Papst. Und das beschreibt ihn schon ganz gut, er wollte Organist werden und Illusionist. Aber irgendwann wollte er auch Mentalist werden. Man ist aus Solidarität manchmal zu Auftritten von ihm gegangen und hat ein bisschen Leute hat er halt so ein bisschen Leute verarscht, hat dann halt so Münzen gehabt und so. Man dachte, ja komm, lass ihn. War nie gut, aber irgendwann ist er diese gefährliche Mentalistenrichtung eingeschlagen, wo er dann wirklich angefangen hat, Leute zu hypnotisieren. Und es hat offensichtlich funktioniert. Und dann denke ich mir auch, Alter, du hast einen Sticker vom Farms auf deinem Keyboard, mach das nicht. Du wahrscheinlich, und er war auch kein guter Magier, jetzt ist es aber, aber jetzt fängt es an, auch gefährlich zu werden, noch übergeppig zu werden, weil Leute offensichtlich ihr Bewusstsein verlieren auf der Bühne.
Man will so hochlaufen und die in die stabile Seitenlage bewegen oder so ein Kram, aber das fängt dann an, gefährlich zu werden, das kannst du nicht machen.
Ja und was flößt ihr denn dann da so ein, wenn die so so, du findest meine Musik gut, ich spiele gleich was auf dem Keyboard.
Du kaufst eine Platte von Binky Sack-Doo. Was? Selbst so im Schlag, wer? Die Hälfte des Publikums hypnotisiert einfach so die ganze Zeit. Sind Leute hypnotisiert gerade? Yeeeey! Aber jetzt im Ernst, also das macht mir... Es ist ja wirklich, weil ich hab mal so eine Doku gesehen von so Leuten, die dann halt so hypnotisiert wurden und dann haben die so ein Gewehr gegeben und dann hat er so gesagt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie schnippe und dann gehst du, dann holst du das Gewehr aus der Kiste, die so aussieht wie eine Gitarrenkiste. Interessantes Detail, aber... Kommt es doch mal vor, sorry?
Damit, ja wenn du so eine Kiste, die aussieht wie ein Gewehr durch die Gegend trägst, dann denkst du dir. Guter Punkt. Jeder weiß, was in einer Gitarrenkiste drin ist. Ja, denkt man. Und dann hat die gesagt, wenn ich jetzt schnippe, dann holst du das Gewehr, gehst in das Hochhaus und schießt auf den Präsidenten, der da gerade spricht. Was ist das für eine Show?
Aber das Gewehr...
Bei Penn & Teller werden Luftballons zu verschwinden gebracht.
Aber, Spoiler-Alarm, das Gewehr war nicht geladen.
Oder nur mit so Quatsch geladen oder so.
Und dann hat man tatsächlich...
Patronen!
Und dann hat er geschnippt und dann hat er das tatsächlich gemacht.
Und dann hat er die Kiste geholt, aus der Gitarre... Also die Gitarre mussiste geholt aus der Gitarre, hat eine Gitarre rausgeholt und Wonderwall gespielt. Und hätte dann den Präsidenten erschossen, wenn, vielleicht war es ein Film, aber es ist auch wirklich, es war wirklich, wo ich mir dachte, wo ich mir dachte, wow, das ist, aber vor allem, ich denke mir so, warum macht man Schnippen? So, dann geht der an so einer Jazzbar vorbei und alles ist ruiniert, einfach so, weil das ist zu, das ist einfach zu, zu offensichtlich, so. Ja, vor allem, da gibt es auch dieses eine Video, wo jemand sagt, er wird hypnotisiert und sagt, sobald du einen roten Ballon siehst, hebst du an diesem Geldautomaten 50 Euro ab und gibst ihn dem Obdachlosen. Und er hat das gemacht. Und danach haben die das auch nicht wieder aufgelöst. Die sind nicht zu den Typen gegangen, haben gesagt, übrigens pass ein bisschen auf, wenn du demnächst auf Kindergeburtstagen bist oder den Film S schaust. Und tatsächlich wird er durch die Welt laufen und einfach ein riesiges Problem ab. Muss man einfach sagen. Die müssen das doch wieder auflösen dann.
Kann man das auflösen, kann man das wieder rückgängig machen?
Sind Illusionisten da, Mentalisten da. Aber das ist doch relativ häufig,
wie viele so Shows, wo jemand mal hypnotisiert wird oder sowas. Wurde schon mal jemand hypnotisiert?
Wirklich? Ja.
Okay, und das war medizinisch oder wirklich auf ne. Und du warst weg dann wirklich, du warst? Ähm, ja, also ich glaube, man muss halt mega krass dafür offen sein. Man muss davor sagen, ich will wirklich mal ein bisschen schwank. Also wenn man mit so einer Gaghaltung reingeht, dann wird es nicht funktionieren. Ja, mach mal, mach mal, mach mal, mach mal, brauchst du den Zauberstab wirklich? Nee, du musst dich selber so in das Feeling reinkriegen. Was für ein Feeling, Jungfräulichkeit. Hohoho, holy shit, was war, hoho, sorry, nein, das war jetzt nicht gegen dich, das war so allgemein gegen die Mangelwelt, so war es jetzt nicht gemeint, deswegen habe ich keine Freundin, glaube ich. Buh, Stefan, Buh, Stefan, Buh, was? Also man muss sich nicht in das viel, ich verstehe, man muss sich darauf einlassen, tief durchatmen. Deswegen war das Quatsch, was du gerade erzählt hast. Okay, danke. Vielen Dank, das du es warst. Aber Moment mal.
Woher weißt du, was du willst?
No.
Woher weißt du, dass du jetzt nicht irgendeinen Präsidenten umbringen willst?
Danke. Okay, aber echt interessant.
Raus!
Interessant, was hast du gemacht dann? Was ist dann passiert? Ich habe mich auf die Stirn getippt und mich nach hinten fallen lassen. Ich wusste nicht, ob da jemand ist, aber überraschenderweise stand da jemand, der mich auf die Stirn getippt.
Oh, stell dir vor, da wäre niemand gewesen.
Wurdest du in ein schwarzes Auto gezogen?
Ich glaube, da wurde es gekidnappt. Mir hat jemand auf die Stirn getippt, da bin ich nach hinten umgefallen, jemand hat mich gepackt.
Da habe ich keine Erinnerung mehr. Aber kannst du so einfach benennen, in wen du als erstes verliebt warst?
Ja.
Ja?
Wen denn?
Wen denn, fragt jemand anderes aus dem Publikum, was eine weirde Eigendynamik ergibt.
Ich könnte das gar nicht so sagen, ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich.
Oder?
Du schon, du bist doch relativ straight, aber du kennst den Namen deines Bruders, aber
das ist kein Bruder. Okay, der erste Fan, der sich zu Wort meldet, wird geroasted. Der wird zu Tode geroasted. Warum machen wir das? Das war nicht so gemein. Aber okay, du hast den Beweis, Hypnose funktioniert. Nicht schlecht. Aber ich denke mir das zum Beispiel auch immer bei diesen Sicherheitsfragen, bei so Passwörtern, wo es dann heißt so, wie heißt ihr erstes Haustier, wo ich immer verleitet bin, als Antwort zu schreiben, keine Ahnung. Sorry, aber ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung. Und viel Spaß mit Florentins Amazon-Profil. Aber dann irgendwann, wenn ich, ich hatte letztens den Fall, kann ich gleich erzählen, ich hatte den Fall wegen meiner Geldkarte, dann ruft jemand an und so, ich bräuchte jetzt nochmal den Namen ihres ersten Haustiers und du, keine Ahnung. Richtig. Komischer Name. Ja, aber was soll diese Sparkassenmitarbeiterin denn machen, wenn da steht, keine Ahnung, und du sagst, keine Ahnung?
Ja, vor allem, also bei mir ist es, der Name meines ersten Haustiers ist Tweety, Wellensittich.
Ja, aber wie schreibt man das?
Stimmt, man hat den Namen nicht geschrieben.
Ich hätte es mit sechs oder so bekommen, da fängst du jetzt, ne, das war ein bisschen alt, aber so mit vier oder so,
und da gibst du den Leuten, da gibst du denen ja einfach einen Namen, aber wusch, du schreibst den ja nicht auf,
oder es gibt keine Geburtsurkunde vom fucking Wannsittich.
Das heißt, du weisst nie, wie er geschrieben wird und goodbye Amazon.
Tweety?
Tweety. Wegen dem Vogel, Tweety. Wegen des Vogels.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Aber wo du gerade Bankkarte ansprichst, die Bankkarten-Storyline geht weiter.
Ich habe ja meine Sparkaskarte verloren.
Sind wir noch ein Topic Island eigentlich?
Wir sind ein Topic Island.
Okay, aber gut. Mal weiter.
Und man will ja einen einfachen Pin, dachte ich, bis dann meine neue Pin kam.
Und es ist ein bisschen schwierig, darüber jetzt zu reden.
Also das ist gefährlich, darüber Gags zu machen.
Okay, das führt zu nicht.
Aber eine Sache würde ich sagen, die neue Pin beinhaltet eine nicht unsignifikante Anzahl an Nullen. Okay, ihr könnt ab jetzt gehen. Wer es als erstes zum Geldautomaten schafft, gewinnt den Jackpot für heute Abend. Aber einer! Und man denkt eine einfache Pinn. Nein, ihr wollt keine einfache Pinn.
Wenn ich jetzt zum Geldautomaten gehe und mir Geld abhole,
sieht das so aus, als ob ich den Entwartungszustand
verletzen will oder sowas.
Ja genau, das sieht wirklich so aus.
Was macht der da?
Und alle sehen sofort meine Pinn.
Alle, weil ich die ganze Zeit...
Das ist doch scheiße.
Es ist interessant, man redet ja selten über seine Pinn.
Aus gutem Grund.
Mir fällt auf, dass ich ein ähnliches Problem habe, meine, na das kann ich nicht sagen, ich sag mal, meine PIN enthält Sonderzeichen. Es ist 0,0 einmal drehen 0,0, aber ich sag mal, ich hab häufiger dieselbe Ziffer. Ich auch.
Ich auch. Der grosse Spoiler, wir haben die gleiche Pinnnummer. Wie geil wäre das denn?
Muss es ja geben, es gibt ja mehr als 10.000 Menschen in Deutschland.
Oh, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Oder?
Tatsächlich, das ist ja voll, natürlich.
Vielleicht müssen irgendwann Buchstaben dazukommen.
Aber gibt es 0, 0, 0 ist voll, natürlich. Vielleicht müssen irgendwann Buchstaben dazukommen. Aber gibt's null null null null? Na. Du hast nicht, nein, nein, du hast nicht die Pinnnummer null null null null, das kann nicht sein. Aber sag mal, wenn man durchprobiert, wenn du rätst, wenn du meine PIN raten müsstest und du fängst an, sagen wir mal durchzuprobieren, dann drei Versuche reichen aus. Ich meine, du hast schon die Telefonnummer 5, das ist deine Telefonnummer, du kannst nicht noch die PIN-Nummer 0000 haben. Das ist wirklich nicht so toll. Aber was macht man da jetzt?
Du kannst ja nicht bei der Sparkasse anrufen und denen die Pinn verraten.
Aber vor allem was ich mache, ich versuche das beim Eintippen zu faken.
Weil man würde das ja hören.
Mit so einem feinen Tuch.
Ich gehe immer davon aus, ich gehe immer davon aus, oder so... Der Automat ist weg.
Ja, ja. Oder so einfach sich umdrehen und dem so Sand in die Augen werfen.
Weil diese Mager nicht immer verschwinden, weil sie so eine Nebelgranate werfen. Und Pernatella wissen, wie er es gemacht hat, aber wir wissen es nicht. Ja, ja. Hat das was mit Rauch zu tun? Ah, fuck, das war es von mir. Aber ich versuche das jetzt tatsächlich immer so zu verdecken, weil man das ja hören würde. Man würde dann hören zum Beispiel... Weil du dabei sagst, eins, zwei, vier...
Man würde hören zum Beispiel, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb.
Nein, nein.
Das ist jetzt aus Versehen auch noch Beethoven gewesen.
Das ist nicht so.
Neider Versuch, Flemmrich.
Aber...
Bei der Fondermann ist es so.
Da gab es immer eine Wetten-Das-Nummer, tatsächlich.
Wie Marco aus Reda-Wiedenburg wettet, dass er die Nummer anhand des Geräusches erkennen kann. Wo man sich auch dachte, es ist nicht so, also wie viele Geräusche gibt es? Also wahrscheinlich maximal zehn Geräusche, weil es ja dann Ziffern gibt, ein, zwei bis neun und null. So hat er halt die Geräusche auswendig gelernt und dann kann er halt ... Ja, ist schon ziemlich cool. Wie? Äh, eigentlich schon.
Ich glaube, in den ersten zwei Staffeln Wetten, das war es mega einfach, da reinzukommen.
Einfach, wo du sagst so, ich kann einen Eimer von seiner Farbe her unterscheiden.
Und du hast keine Referenz als Redakteur, weisst du nicht.
Ist es schwer, ich weiss nicht.
Ich kann es nicht, aber ...
Der Typ, der das immer testen musste.
Ja, ja.
Da gab es einen Typ, der die ganzen Wetten testen musste und immer herausprobieren musste, ob das machbar ist oder nicht. Krass. Ja, es ist schwer, wenn du mit so einer Show anfängst und nur Trottel das schauen, weil immer wenn eine Show anfängt, schauen erst mal nur Idioten zu und dann irgendwann kommen die coolen. Irgendwann kommen die coolen Zuhörer dazu. Und dann ist es schwer, wenn sich nur dumme Leute bewerben. Aber was ich zumindest jetzt immer versuche, ist, ich versuche, ich versuche, Phantomdrücker zu machen beim Eingeben, wo ich so tue, als würde ich draufdrücken. Also Baum hat ja acht Ziffern. Ja, aber du weißt ja nicht, welche acht, welche vier oder fünf in den acht. Also ich mache so den Wirbel, so zack, zack, zack, ganz schnell, und man weiß nicht, wo ich hindrüücke. Ich betröste mich einfach damit, dass die Leute meine Karte und meine PIN brauchen, das ist meine einzige Hoffnung. Ne, nicht im Internet. Was? Nicht im Internet. Aber brauchen die meine Karte? Ne. Hier, hier, meine Karten, nehmt sie! Auf der Karte ist die Sperrnummer drauf, um die Karte zu sperren. Das ist der letzte Ort, wo man die Nummer braucht, um die Karte zu sperren. Also der richtiger Tritt ins Gesicht, ja. 116116. Tatsächlich, ja. Es ist wirklich die Ziffer. Niemand lacht, weil es aber stimmt nicht. Da sind Leute beeindruckt, ja. Aber das stimmt wirklich, 116116. Ja, ja, tatsächlich. Jetzt habt ihr alle was gelernt, jetzt hat sie schon gelohnt. Ich falle vorher, die ich verloren habe, das war so eine weirde, die hat so ein komisches Symbol drauf, weil ich noch sehr klein war, dass ich zum ersten Mal bekomme, ob diese Karte. Und dann konnte ich mir so Symbole aussuchen, so am Strand oder so ein Traktor. Und ich hatte halt die Kassette und dachte mir, Gott sei Dank, jetzt verliere ich die, okay, ist doof, aber man kann sie sperren lassen. und Gott sei Dank bin ich jetzt diese Kassette weg. Aber in Köln tatsächlich ist es ein bisschen weird, wenn du eine Karte, du musst dich wieder ein Symbol aussuchen, und du hast die Wahl zwischen den Kölner Hain oder dem Kölner FC.
Und jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen einen Mitgliedsausweis von den Kölner Hain mit so einem Puck, es ist echt wirklich.
Also Köln macht sich da auch nicht, einfach keine Freunde mit tatsächlich, Symbole.
Vor allem das einzige, es gibt den Dom, wow, okay,, wir haben einfach keine Freunde mit tatsächlich. Das sind Brülle. Vor allem das einzige...
Es gibt den Dom.
Es gibt den Dom, wow, okay. Aber den wollte ich... Der war mir zu generisch tatsächlich.
Du hast den Dom.
Warum nicht die Kölner Haie?
Aber ist uncool, Kölner Haie, ist alles cool?
Also wir haben Stefans...
Wir haben Stefans...
Bist du, man fachst gerade von eins bis zehn. Ist cool? Ist nicht cool? Also wir haben Stephans Pin und wir wissen, wie seine Geldkarte aussieht.
Okay, ich bin ab jetzt ruhig.
Im Laufe des Abends, Puzzlestück, so die neue Staffel Schörer.
Im Cluedo-Spiel, am Ende weiß man.
Ja, am Ende kriegt einer den grossen Jackpot.
Finde ich gut.
Ah, Rook-Luedo, kennst du das, wenn man am Bahnsteig steht und dann kommt diese Durchsage, dass Trickdiebe unterwegs sind und man steht am Bahnsteig mit einer Oma mit grauen Haaren und dem Model im gelben Kleid und reverend grün und man steht da und alle haben automatisch diese sofort sind alle verdächtig und man selber ist auch der verdächtige von anderen und es ist alle halten die taschen fest und man überlegt sich jetzt wer von denen ist es wenn am bahnhof Trickbetrüger unterwegs sind wer von euch war's oder bin ich selbst da bin ich selbst ich bin eher so ein Dieb ich bin eher ein Dieb kein Trickbetrüger das betrifft mich nicht Ja, das stimmt. Aber ist Ich bin eher so ein Dieb, ich bin eher ein Dieb, kein Trickbetrüger.
Das betrifft mich nicht. Aus Versehen.
Das stimmt.
Aber ist das dann gut oder schlecht für den Trickbetrüger?
Ist das dann so sein Fame so ein bisschen, so wie ein Serienmörder, der dann in der Zeitung steht?
So ein bisschen, der halt dann so ausgerufen wird?
Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Wahrscheinlich findet er das gut.
Aber er muss den Bahnhof wechseln wahrscheinlich.
Ist hier jemand Trickbetrüger?
So wie bei Ikea sich ausrufen lassen. Ich fand das immer cool. Vorhin kam meine Mutter, was ist denn, was ist denn, ich wollte nur ausgerufen werden. Und der, ich dachte das wäre ein Gag, aber der Besitz, der Gründer von Ikea ist im Smallland gestorben. In der Stadt Smallland. Doch, das ist eine Stadt in Schweden. Und es war seine Heimatstadt und da ist er gestorben. Nein, du hast eine...
Smallland und ich dachte, das wäre ein Witz bei Twitter und ihr denkt auch, es wäre ein Witz bei Twitter, weil niemand lachte über dieses Bit und es stimmt.
Es war ein Witz.
Oh, da ist eine Kontaktlinse rausgefallen.
Natürlich war es ein Witz.
Nein, der ist ein...
Ja, und du meinst, sein Körper wurde zu Kotbüller verarbeitet oder was? Das ist auch kein Witz. Biu, biu, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,itzer googeln, weil man in China weiß, wie er heisst. Ingwer Kampfrath. Ich muss erst mal dein Passwort drauf sagen. Ja, waren da viele Lachsmileys drunter, Stefan? Waren da Loils und Lells drunter, Stefan? War es ein Witz? Er ist eigentlich bei Expedit gestorben. Nein, er ist nicht da gestorben, ist nicht im Smallland gestorben. Das war doch ein Tweet. Von Satire.de. Aber Smallland ist doch eine Stadt in Schweden, oder nicht? Nein, das ist einfach wegen Small Klein. Naja, aber da ist ja dieses Kreis über dem A. Ja, das macht es trotzdem nicht zu einem echten Land, das ist trotzdem ein Wortspiel. Naja, aber es bedient sich zumindest dem schwedischen Alphabet. Aber Batman hat doch einen Umhang, der muss doch echt sein. Das ist auch mal jetzt. Ist okay. Ach ja. Wie unangenehm wäre es, wenn ich das nicht aufkriegen würde. Das ist einfach... Ja, vor allem, ich habe jetzt vier Flaschen. Die erste ist schon weg. Ich kriege, es ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm zu sagen, aber ich kriege recht häufig Sachen nicht auf. Muss ich auch mal sagen. Ich kriege sehr häufig Sachen nicht auf und denke mir dann so, welche Menschen haben diese Produzenten im Auge, wenn die das produzieren, was haben die für kräftige Menschen im Sinne? Oder bin ich einfach nur extrem schwach? Aber trotzdem willst du in Gruppen, wo jemand was nicht aufbekommt, derjenige sein, der es für alle aufmacht, oder? Ja, das ist der größte Druckmoment aller Zeiten, wenn dir jemand so etwas gibt, um es aufzumachen, und du kannst es immer noch nicht. Und du hast dein Batman-Cape an, das ist einfach eine ganz, ganz schlechte Kombination. Das ist ein grosser Druckmoment oder wie gesagt, wenn man bei einer Bahn der erste ist am Aufstieg und die nicht aufbekommt. Apropos Batman, ich habe letztens, manchmal stösst man so auf Tatorte, habe ich das Gefühl. Ich habe letztens, wollte ich mit dem Car-to-Go fahren und dann bin ich ins Car-to-Go eingestiegen und war... Oh Gott!
Nein, nein, nein, keine Angst, keine Angst, keine Angst, keine Angst, keine Angst, keine Angst, steckt das Teleskop wieder ein, keine Angst. Und zwar, ich mache die Tür auf zum Car2Go und finde das Car2Go, dieses Auto... War dein Car2Go der Tatort? Was hast du gemacht? Ich finde diesen Smart in folgender Konstellation, und zwar ist der Sicherheitsgurt vom Beifahrersitz eingesteckt in die Buchse des Fahrersitzes und spannt sich so über den ganzen Beifahrersitz. Und ich schaue das so an und denke mir, ist das eine Falle? Irgendwie bin ich jetzt, wenn ich mich da jetzt hinsetze, weil ich zum Beispiel, ich bin, ich bin großer Fan von Detektiv Conan, so, und da ist es immer so, da ist es immer so, da ist es immer so, kommt jetzt, ihr wisst selber, wo ihr im Leben falsch abgewogen seid, es ist einfach, es ist einfach, und dann gibt es da immer, die hören Podcast-Ufo. Und dann gibt es ja immer so die Situation, und dann denkt man so, ja gut, der hat den halt mit dem Messer umgebracht, der kann nicht jetzt wegschalten, kann wieder weg von Togo-TV
wegschalten. Und dann schaut man da immer so die Situation so und dann denkt man so, ja gut, der hat den halt mit dem Messer umgebracht, der kann nicht jetzt wegschalten, kann wieder weg von TogoTV wegschalten. Und dann schaut man den, was ist denn da hinten los, Mensch, Leute? Jesus Christ! Aber das passiert mir auch häufig, weil man hat halt begrenzt Platz unten, die Flasche hinzustellen und man neigt halt dazu, manchmal die Beine auszustrecken. Also eine Solidarität mit Leuten, die das machen.
Und du denkst dir, der wurde einfach mit einem Messer umgebracht und dann schaust du dir die Folgedetektiv Conan bis zu Ende an und dann heisst es ja nie, der hat irgendwie so eine Konstruktion, so einen durchsichtigen Faden über die Tür hintendurch und das hat er mit einem Tesafilm so befestigt, dass wenn man zieht, zieht sich das automatisch durch und das hinterlässt keine Spuren. Und ich denke immer so, was ist, wenn in der Situation jemand das so...
Führte dieses vom Fernseher mit sechs Jahren Bullshit, Bullshit sich das automatisch durch und das hinterlässt keine Spuren. Und ich denke immer so, was ist wenn in der Situation jemand da so...
Puh, die sitzt vom Fernseher mit sechs Jahren, Bullshit, Bullshit, das geht nicht.
Oder immer so, so bringe ich meinen Bruder um. Gute Idee, gute Idee. Und ich denke immer so, dann ist da irgendwie so ein Besen irgendwo dagegen geklemmt und dann irgendwie so die Fake-Leiche, die dann irgendwie zum Fenster rauskommt.
Ich denke immer so, was wäre, wenn jemand da vorbeilaufen würde, beacht dieser Konstruktion. Einfach so, wo alles so und dann der Mörder so. Okay, aber du warst der Meinung, dass dein Car to go war, diese Situation. Ich dachte, irgendwas wird hier noch passieren. Dass irgendjemand genauso und dann weißt du, wenn er den abschließt, dann geht er da raus und zieht das dann durchs Fenster irgendwie durch und zieht von außen den Schlüssel rein, so dass der Schlüssel drin ist und das Auto aber noch läuft oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und ich hatte echt großen Respekt, ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll. Aber Car2Go, ich glaube, die lassen so ein bisschen nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob das relatable ist oder ob die meisten nicht auch in die Car2Go-Kauf fahren. Das sind alles Drive-Now-Fahrer im Podcast. Aber genau, ich bin auch mit Car2Go in euch gefahren in Berlin und dann ist plötzlich einfach das Auto stehen geblieben. Mitten auf der fucking Strasse, das war wirklich so eine 70er-Zone und das Auto sprang nicht mehr an. 70er Jahre oder? Man konnte 70 fahren. Und dann plötzlich kam es so eine Art Stau und mein Auto hält an und die Start-Stop-Automatik beginnt und es sprang nicht wieder an. Und irgendwann löst sich der Stau so langsam auf und ich habe die ganze Zeit einfach den hier gemacht. Bin erstmal ruhig geblieben, das lernt man ja, ruhig bleiben, durchatmen und den machen. Und immer durch die Zähne, komm schon, komm schon sagen. Das ist ein bisschen länger gemacht, aber es ging nicht. Und irgendwann hat sich dieser Stau aufgelöst und Leute sind hinter mir mit 70 herangerast und ich sass da und habe den nicht anbekommen.
Und dann wundere ich mich, warum man in Berlin immer, also ich habe immer die Erfahrung gemacht, dass in Köln sind Leute sehr nett und in Berlin, nichts geht, das Publikum von dem letzten Mal, aber in Berlin sind Leute halt immer so ein bisschen, also ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich komme mit einem Streiz mit Leuten in Berlin. Sobald man ins Taxi steigt, ist es immer so ein bisschen direkt so ein bisschen miese Stimmung einfach.
Und das war genau so, natürlich, obviously, weil Leute vorbeigefahren sind und gesagt haben, ey du Offe, du kannst doch nicht stehen bleiben. Ich dachte, ich weiss das, niemand bleibt hier stehen, weil er es will. Ich versuche doch alles, um es wieder ans Laufen zu bekommen, aber die Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt. Was will man denn machen, ausser den hier? Was willst du denn machen? Komm schon, jetzt komm schon. Und dann ging er wieder an, dachte mir auch so, Kato, komm, warum müssen wir noch versuchen, ein anständiges Unternehmen zu sein, was so ein bisschen versucht, zumindest Leute von A nach B zu bringen. Augenständig nicht mehr. Mittlerweile sind Tatorte und bei mir wäre es auch fast ein Tatort geworden. Und, ein großes Problem von mir, der Aschenbecher, Zigaretten im Aschenbecher. Und die Frage ist, was macht man dann? Weil du denkst hier, also... Aufrauchen. Noch den Rest und vor allem, erst dachte ich, man könnte das so rauslösen und dann so... Raucher haben ja so ganz viele coole Gesten, so dieses Wegschnippen und dann so dieses das hier, keine Ahnung, was das ist jetzt hier. Lieben Gross an die Podcast-Hörer, dafür der Aufnahme, das hier, keine Ahnung, aber viele coolere, dieses Wegschnippen, so alles cool und dazu gehört auch der Aschenbecher. Aber so während der Fahrt einfach so, ja auf jeden Fall, keine Ahnung, ich treffe mich jetzt irgendwie nur noch seltener mit ihr, weil ich dachte mir irgendwie so, whoop, und das ist einfach cool. Das Auto hinter einem in Flammen, pfff. Aber ging nicht, ich konnte es nicht raus machen und ich musste es dann und dann dachte ich mir, ich schaufel's raus.
Ich schaufel's raus es dann dachte ich mir schaufels raus ich schaufels raus und dann dachte ich mir lässt es nicht einfach da ist wie es alle machen ich sag mal so ich bin momentan in der in der kritischen phase meines lebens ich bin ich bin arbeitslos ich schaue den ganzen tag detective cotton und wenn ich schon welche an wenn ich jetzt irgendwo auftauchen würde und nach rauch riechen würde, wissen Leute einfach, okay, jetzt ist er ein anderer Mensch, jetzt ist er völlig abgestürzt. Ich will ehrlich, das kannst du mir vorstellen. Ich versuche immer schon, auch so, wenn ich Milchflecken auf dem T-Shirt habe, dann denke ich mir so, ich kann jetzt nicht, ich kann jetzt nicht mit Milchflecken auftauchen. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, kann ich nicht machen. Ich schaufel es raus. Aber dann dachte ich mir, ich baue mir einen Taschentuch-Handschuh. Klassischer TH. Jeder kennt ihn, jeder hat ihn an der Beine. Klassischer TTH einfach, schön. Und dann habe ich mir, weil es geht ja, du kannst hier, ich glaube, du brauchst vier Blätter. Das ist eine Matheaufg für alldauersen wie macht man aus vier taschentuchblättern perfekten handschuh vier finger kleiner tipp an der stelle vier finger und dann kannst du schön rein einfach und dann habe ich alles rausgerödelt und dann kannst du es in den taschen in den fußraum erst mal direkt einfangen und dann wollte ich es raustun und habe alle über mich drüber geschreut direkt über mich drüber und habe ich dann habe ich gedacht, okay, jetzt rieche ich nicht nur nach Rauch. Das war die Ausrede, die ihr mir erzählt hat, weil er es nach Rauch riecht. Und Leute denken, was ja nicht so fruchtbar ist, aber man will nicht Raucher sein, man will kein schlechter Raucher sein, oder? Das ist glaube ich so das Ding, man will nicht der Raucher sein, der noch Asche auf dem T-Shirt hat. So einfach so, ja, ja, ja, ich rauche jetzt auch einfach so alles voller Asche. Irgendwie so, was hast du falsch verstanden? Ich glaube, ich habe einmal in meinem Leben eine Zigarette geraucht und man hat das auch einfach gesehen, weil wenn man zum ersten Mal raucht, hast du das Gefühl, also dir ist bewusst, dass eine Seite sehr heiß ist. Das ist dir bewusst einfach und deswegen nimmst du die nicht wie alle anderen, die einfach so nebenbei so ein bisschen dann den machen, sondern du hast dann halt einfach, du bist halt vorsichtig. Skeptisch einfach. Bist vorsichtig. Als Kind mal, das führt nicht wohin, aber ganz kurz, einfach so ein bisschen eine kleine Anekdote mal eingeschoben. Bei einer Hochzeit von einem Freund meiner Eltern habe ich einfach als Kind meinem Vater in die Zigarette gefasst und habe die ganze Hochzeit geschrien. Die ganze Hochzeit ruiniert! Einfach wollen Sie den hier anwesenden Manfred? Das ist eine doofe Idee auch einfach. Vor allem dann versteht man ja auch, warum man weint, weil das einfach weh tut. Aber wolltest du ihn davon abhalten zu rauchen oder wolltest du ihn auf die Gefahr? Ja genau, aber die viel wichtigere Frage ist doch, warum raucht mein Vater während der Hochzeitstrauung? Es waren die 70er, ich weiss es nicht. Was war das für eine Zeit, wo du in der Kirche die einfach einen angemacht hast? Hostie rein, wieder die Zigarette. Was ist das für eine Zeit? Es waren die wilden Jahre, das war die wilden Jahre. Das schlechte Horror. Ja, habt ihr irgendwas erlebt? Ich will die Vorstellung einfach so lustig, wenn man so ein Rauch hat, der so Asche im Haar hat.
Einfach so, was machst du falsch? Ich dachte als Kind immer, ich lebte in der Illusion des perfekten Kreises, aber der existiert nicht. Und zwar dachte ich, dass die Asche von Zigaretten wieder in Zigarettenpapier eingerollt wird, um neue Zigaretten zu machen. Genau wie ich dachte, dass man so den Kaffee, der in Kaffeefiltern ist, wieder trocknet, um neuen Kaffee zu machen. Ich dachte, alles ist so ein konstanter Kreislauf, weil das hat total Sinn ergeben. Dann wirft man das weg und dann sammeln die das irgendwo, dann trocknen die das und machen einen neuen Kaffee draus und dann geht das wieder von vorne los. Es ist auch so. Okay, ja, sehr gut. Nur es dauert halt länger. Also die Dinge werden dann irgendwann zu Müll und er zersetzt sich dann und in Tausenden von Jahren ist vielleicht aus dem Kaffee wieder ein Kaffee geworden. Denn alles ist ein Kreis, wie wir bei König der Löwen gelernt haben. Oder nicht jetzt, oder ist es Quatsch? Ich verstehe immer noch nicht genau, wie das Leben ist ein Kreis, der Gazelle helfen soll, die von einem Löwen gefressen wird. Weil das die beste Fluchtroute ist. Lauf einfach im Kreis, das Leben ist ein Kreis. Eigentlich nur für die Gazelle. Was für ein Scheisssong, oder? Sorry, die Gazelle lebt ihr ganzes Leben lang in Angst, aufgefressen zu werden, und Phil Collins' Circle of Life. Ich wäre trotzdem gefressen, Mann, was soll das denn? Niemand frisst den Löwen, der Löwe frisst mich, was ist das für ein scheiss Kreis? Das ist kein Kreis, wo ist das ein Kreis? Der Kreis wäre, Löwe frisst mich, ich fress Löwe, das wäre ein Greis. Das wäre fair. So ist es nicht. Scheiss Kreis, ey. Was ist das für ein dummer Spruch? Life is a bitch. The circle of life. Na ja, ist schon ein Circle. Naja, es ist so ein Trapez, glaube ich. So ein ungleichmässiges Trapez. Das ist so ein bisschen so schief. Dikosa-Eder, sehr kompliziert.
So einfach brutales Tier tötet weniger brutales Tier bis zum schwachen Tier und dann so und dann geht's wieder von oben los.
Aber das ist so ein bisschen der uncoole Teil, das passiert dann irgendwie schon.
Wir wollen die Gazellen rennen sehen, renngazelle.
Stehst du auf Konfrontation?
Ja, ich liebe Konfrontation.
Ich nicht so. Also manchmal kennt man das ja, wenn man sich... Du weißt eine gute Gazelle, glaube ich. Ich denke mir manchmal so, manchmal hat man so einen Hochstatus, also ich finde das Prinzip Hochstatus, Tiefstatus sehr interessant, weil man muss sich immer bewusst sein, wann hat man eigentlich gerade einen Hochstatus und wann sagt die Gesellschaft auch, du hast ihn gerade verdient, du bist es cool gerade, was du machst, du musst dich dafür einsetzen, für dein Recht einsetzen.
Und dann war es so, ich habe Pizza bestellt. Und dann kam es dazu, dass plötzlich der Lieferant mich anruft und sagt, ja, wo sind sie? Und ich, ach ja, wo sind sie? Das ist die berechtigere Frage. Und er hat dann tatsächlich das Essen zu meiner Firma bestellt.
Da wo ich arbeite.
Stefan Tietze Unlimited oder wie?
Stefan Tietze Unlimited oder wie. Stefan Tietze AG. Da, wo ich arbeite, da ist es hingelaufen, weil ich die falsche Adresse eingegeben habe. Und das ist natürlich doof. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, sorry, musste er durch ganz Köln fahren und dann zurück. Da dachte ich mir, okay, gut, das ist schon ein bisschen doof gelaufen, aber naja, das wird ja häufiger passieren. Und dann ruft mich die Filiale an und der war nicht mehr so nett dann. Und er hat angerufen und gesagt, das ist ja nicht scheissernst, der Typ hat ja Feierabend eigentlich und der muss jetzt in Zweifelstund durch Köln gurken, um ihm die scheiss Pizza zu geben. Und ich dachte mir, das kann ja nicht sein, der ruft mich hier an und macht mich einfach an. Und ich bin der Kunde, die Kunden sind König, oder nicht? Und dann habe ich dem gesagt, das ist jetzt schon ziemlich uncool, wie sie mich hier anmaulen. Und dann hat er gesagt, weil ich dachte, ja komm, Hochstatus, du hast Hochstatus, einfach mal ein bisschen, ich bin immer zu nett zu leuten, aber ich habe gesagt, komm, das kann ja nicht sein, wie sie mich hier anmachen, ich bestelle nur Pizza, ist doch alles gut, fahren Sie einfach durch Köln, alles cool, meine Pinnummer ist 001, das könnte ich mir gar nichts anzahlen. Und dann hat der Typ gute Argumente gesagt, er hat gesagt, ja, Sie haben die Adresse falsch eingegeben, das liegt bei Ihnen, er hat mich auch wirklich, er hat mich zurück zu Sau gemacht und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, stimmt eigentlich. Und das hat, und er so, er war noch voll im Rant und meinte dann so, bitte, was haben Sie gerade gesagt? Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ja, klar, Sie haben voll recht, ich gebe einfach dem Typen dann mehr Geld, einfach der gleich mit mir steht. Und der war noch nie so verwirrt in seinem Leben, weil das kennt der nicht. Also es war offensichtlich neu für den, dass man so schnell einfach den ganzen Status ändert, um keine Konfrontation zu bekommen. Weil ich hatte so Angst davor plötzlich und der hatte natürlich Recht, aber ich dachte mir einfach aus Scheiss mal einfach jetzt, vielleicht habe ich die Rechte, vielleicht liegt der Fehler nicht bei mir und habe gesagt, ja was soll denn der Scheiss und der Typ hat mich zu Recht in die Schranken gewiesen. Und dann hab ich gesagt, okay, das war interessant, der war echt verwirrt in seinem Leben, hat auch nett aufgeholt, aufgelegt, danach war das wieder cool. Ja, vielleicht hat der Autofahrer bei dir ähnliche Regeln so, warum stehst du da? Ja, ich will ja nicht stehen, guter Punkt. Guter Punkt. Sorry, ich nehme alles zurück. Viel Erfolg. Ja, also man rechnet nicht damit, dass die sowas aufhören. Man rechnet nicht damit! Wir hatten eine andere, eine lustige Aktion in New York, haben wir eine lustige Situation erlebt, als wir in New York waren, weil wir reisen müssen und wir sind. Weil wir mit einem Flugzeug hin geflogen sind. Da hatten wir aber eine andere lustige Situation von Hochstaat aus Tiefstaat, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich daran noch erinnere, aberst aber wir sind im kiosk gegangen wo ein indischer ist wichtig für die story wo ein indischer herr ist wichtig für unseren rassismus genau wo ein indischer herr hinter dem tresen stand und wir mussten aufs klo ich weiß nicht mehr was war ich glaube der kollege thakan der auch heute hier ist. Tarkan war, musste glaube ich aufs Klo. Wir klauen dir gerade deine Story, hey, deine Story! Und ich glaube, der musste dann aufs Klo und dann ist er zu diesem Typen, sind wir dann gegangen und haben gesagt, wo ist die Schilette, dann haben wir uns die Tür gezeigt und wir sind da hingegangen und die war abgeschlossen. Und dann sind wir zurückgegangen und haben gesagt, ja, the door is locked. Und er so, ja. Aber wie man das so kennt, also so indisch nett, halt so, ja. Und wir dachten so, ja, alles klar, wir würden gehen aufs Klo und die Tür ist abgeschlossen. Und er hat wieder gesagt, ja. Und wir dachten so, holy shit, was ist denn jetzt gerade los? Was für ein Arschloch. Was für ein scheiß Arschloch oder was für ein dummer Idiot einfach. Bis ich rausstellte, dass dann da jemand rauskam. Wo man sagen muss, ja, das war... Ja, stimmt. Der Fehler liegt bei uns. Und dann plötzlich merkt man einfach so einen Shift im Raum. Einfach jetzt hat sich Hochstatus-Tiefstatus massiv verändert. Das war billig. Da hätte man dabei sein müssen. Es gibt ja so dieses Ding, dass man für die Toilettenbenutzung etwas kaufen muss,
so dieses kann ich auf die Toilette nur für Kunden und dann ist immer so, welches Produkt
nimmt man dann, was ist so das Frustrationsprodukt? Man will nicht das billigste nehmen, aber man
will eigentlich das billigste nehmen. Man will eigentlich das billigste nehmen, aber ich denke
immer so, was das für eine Beleidigung für dieses Produkt ist, dann gewählt zu werden,. Dieser Claim, kauf mich, wenn du wirklich nichts kaufen willst oder einfach nur irgendwas kaufen musst, kauf eine Packung Fisherman's Friend.
So einfach, dafür ist es da, um irgendwas zu kaufen.
Was ist überhaupt ein Kunde?
Jetzt wird es interessant.
Kann man da nicht einfach, also angenommen, du kannst mit einer Pfannflasche, gehst du rein und gibst ihm die Pfandflasche und kriegst Pfand zurück und dann bist du dann Kunde? Kannst du noch aufs Klo gehen? Was ist, wenn du dich nur umschaust? Sie dürfen nur aufs Klo, wenn sie sich umschauen. Okay. Wenn du kurz in die Wendy schaust. Was haben sie denn? Kurz durch die Wendy blättern. Bin ich Kunde? Vielleicht Kunde? Sie müssen ein Kundengespräch führen. Aha. Was war dein unangenehmstes Kundengespräch? Unangenehmstes Kundengespräch? Ich glaube, als ich mir mal einen Anzug gekauft habe, dann fragte diese Person dich, wie viel möchten sie denn ausgeben für einen Anzug. Und dann die Frage, was kostet denn ein Anzug? Und du denkst einfach so, das ist die ein Millionen Euro Frage, du hast wirklich keine Ahnung. Und du denkst immer so, kann ich ganz kurz einen Moment geben, ich gehe kurz nach Hause und schaue auf Amazon. Und dann habe ich gesagt, 200 Euro. Und ich weiss bis heute nicht. Das lachen auch nicht alle. Das kann okay sein, das kann ein guter Preis sein. Die Publikusreaktion irritiert mich jetzt auch ein bisschen. Keine Ahnung. So, und dann bringt die mir einen Anzug für 180 Euro und einen für 480 Euro. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir schon so, äh, was? Also was ist jetzt, wer ist jetzt der Dumme hier von beiden? Also bin, oder, also offensichtlich möchten sie mir jetzt diesen Anzug verkaufen, der viel zu teuer ist, und ja, dann auch so diese beiden Anzüge. ja, den einen an und sie meinte, ja gut, natürlich, der sitzt natürlich jetzt nicht so ideal, da muss man natürlich gucken, die Falte ist jetzt nicht mehr. Die Chance mal an einen anderen Anzug, ziehe ich den anderen Anzug an, ja das ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Schneller, das ist perfekt, das ist natürlich so, ach wirklich, der 300 Euro mehr kostet, den finden Sie besser? Das war so ein bisschen und dann... Aber das ist wirklich interessant, weil Verkäufer, ich habe die nicht ganz durchschaut, wollen die einem das verkaufen, was mehr kostet oder wollen die einfach nur das, was was du das kaufst? Hör da auf, genau das. Ja? Ja. Naja, ist ja uncool. Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt. Dann sind das ja Arschlöcher. Aber es ist so durchschaubar. Es ist so durchschaubar. Hätte sie jetzt einen für 180 und einen für 220 genommen, okay. Aber für 84, das war dann so, also das war eine Kommunikation, die so krass auf zwei Ebenen funktioniert hat, weil man hat immer Dinge gesagt und der Subtext war so schreiend laut, man hat gesagt, naja, ich finde den anderen auch nicht schlecht. A.K.A., ich habe kein Geld. Und dann die andere, naja gut, aber der andere Anzug hatte auch einen sehr schönen Stoff. A.K.A., wie aber willst du mir jetzt so direkt zeigen, dass du kein Geld hast? ist dir das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen unangenehm? Aber sie ist besser in dem subtilen Sprechen, weil sie mehr weiß über Anzeige. Ja, total. Und dann am Ende, und dann sagt sie, also irgendwo hört dann auch die Subjektivität auf, die Objektivität auf, sie sagt dann so, nee, also ich würde den nehmen. Sie wären voll Idiot, wenn sie den anderen nehmen würden. Sie wären nämlich nicht nur arm, sondern auch dumm, wenn sie den nehmen würden. Und ich so, ich hab's mir jetzt noch mal überlegt, aber ich nehme den für 180. Egal was dieses Gespräch beinhaltet hat, ich widerspreche ihn in jedem einzelnen Punkt und tue genau das, was sie nicht wollten und sie, okay. bringe ich ihn zur Kasse. Einfach, das war schon sehr unangenehm. Dann bringe ich ihn kurz zur Kasse. Und ich musste einmal ein Foto entwickeln, eins. Also das war wirklich, und ihr habt jetzt wahrscheinlich alle im Kopf so 1824 so, nee, es war vorletztes Jahr und ich habe, ich brauche ein Foto entwickelt und es war dann wirklich so, ja, ich würde gerne ein Foto entwickeln, ich habe es hier auf diesem USB-Stick, war da irgendwo keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Lichtstrahl auf dem USB-Stick und die Verkäuferin so, was ist das, vor allem Geschöpft aus einer anderen Zeit.
Ich muss kurz ein Telegramm schicken, ich rufe kurz den Chef und alle Fotoläden, die noch entwickeln in Deutschland, in Köln ist was passiert.
Und vor allem, es ist ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr da Erfahrungen gemacht habt mit Fotoentwickeln, aber da gibt's keine Privatsphäre, null, also gar nicht mal so den Hauch, einfach so. Er macht dann 24 Cent. Okay, danke. Aber wirklich so no bullshit, einfach nicht so, irgendwie wie man es normalerweise bei Produkten macht, dann irgendwie so, oh, 180 Euro Anzug, so, sondern einfach so straight drauf geguckt. Ja, vor allem, ich habe, man ist ja auch so ein bisschen Hipster, ist man ja schon, da habe ich mir so eine analoge Kamera gekauft für New York. Ähm, ja okay. Vielleicht soll ich auch... Und habt ihr dann... Die Leute hassen Analogkamera.
Sehr einseitiges Publikum heute hier. Und dann habe ich die Fotos mitgemacht und ich habe schon gemerkt, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert oder wird auch nicht so viel funktioniert haben. Und dann habe ich das dann auch in diesen Job direkt am Kölner Dom gebracht, habe dem dann die Kamera die Filme gegeben und habe die dann zurückbekommen irgendwann. Dann wurde ich angerufen und soll die abholen Und ich dachte schon, wenn das jetzt, ich werde ein paar Fotos daneben, ich werde auch den meisten welchen Finger haben, die meisten werden zu dunkel sein oder zu hell. Und ich dachte mir, ja, aber wenn das passiert ist, wirst du es merken, wenn du die Bilder bekommst von dem. Und nicht, weil du sie siehst, sondern an der Reaktion von dem Typen, wenn du die Bilder so rüberschiebt, für die du gerade pro Bild irgendwie ein Euro zahlst oder so. Und tatsächlich, da kam ich da rein und er hat schon gesagt,
so, Herr Tietze, vor allem umrahmt von überall Spiegelreflexkameras, überall die modernste
Technik und er sass mich da mit meiner Umhängekamera reinkommen, hat er dann schon dieses Paket,
so exponiert auch ausgestellt, dann so, hier, ihre Bilder. Hier, ihre Bilder. Viel Spaß. Schöne Finger. Und tatsächlich sind die meisten nicht gut geworden. Aber eins habe ich von dir und Katja, von dir und Katjana Gertz, ein ganz tolles Bild. Da ist irgendwie der Film, irgendwas ist passiert, der ist ausgelaufen, keine Ahnung, irgendwas ist passiert, da muss so etwas schief gelaufen sein, der ist so gelb und er sieht einfach aus wie ein schöner Instagram-Filter, das muss man so sagen, das werde ich mal hochladen, es sieht aus wie ein Filter, aber es ist einfach sehr schlecht fotografiert. Einfach nur Säure, im Grunde sind Instagram-Filter einfach nur Säure, die ausgelaufen. Eigentlich schon, eigentlich schon. Aber vielleicht fragt ihr euch jetzt, ja Mensch Florentin, warum brauchst du denn ein entwickeltes Bild? Wofür brauchst du ein entwickeltes Foto? Und ich kann euch die Geschichte erzählen von dem vielleicht besten Date aller Zeiten. Und zwar, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment von Louis C.K., weil es jetzt kommt. Aber es ist tatsächlich nicht gut im Sinne von erfolgreich, sondern wo ich sage, da habe ich abgeliefert. Also aus einer Performersicht war das Date gut, im Sinne von es war ein guter Auftritt. Ich sage mal, ein guter Auftritt ohne Aftershow-Party, nennen wir es so. Und vor allem, es gab mal eine ich wo ich auf tinder aktiv war und wo ich ein
ein tinder match hatte und wir hatten uns verabredet zum treffen und ich dachte mir
und ich dachte mir das ist einfach eine chance die kriegt man nur einmal im leben und zwar nein Nein, nein, nein, nicht das ...
Nicht das ...
Mir ist vor allem erst aufgefallen, als das Publikum gelacht hat.
Nicht das Match selbst. So, und man guckt sich ja dann das Profil immer mal wieder an und so, um das Gesicht nicht zu vergessen, um sich so ein bisschen einzuprägen. Und dann ist was passiert. Und dann ist plötzlich was passiert. Und zwar zwei Tage vor unserem angedachten Date ändert sich plötzlich was auf ihrem Profil. Ist jetzt ein Mann. Du freust dich noch mehr. Und zwar ändert sich ihr Alter auf 15. Nein, nein nein, nein, keine Angst, keine Angst, keine Angst. Und zwar, ihr Alter ändert sich und ich dachte mir, Moment mal, ich habe fünfzig Staffeln Detektiv Conan gesehen, ich weiss was das heisst. Ihr Alter ändert sich, also hatte sie Geburtstag. Oder ein Fake-Profil. Oder? Oder? So. Jetzt sagte ich mir, okay, Moment mal, wir haben ein Tinder-Date und sie hatte vor zwei Tagen Geburtstag. Ich bringe ihr ein Geschenk mit. Wie, ja, ja, ja, ich merke schon, wie geil ist das denn, bei einem Tinder-Date ein Geschenk dabei zu haben? Ich fände es so gut, wenn du so einen Date-Ratgeber rausbringst, wo du nur diesen einen Tipp hast. Einfach so, der Tipp und danach Gutscheine, einfach so. Der in einem sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlichen Moment eintreten könnte, wenn ihr ein Date hättet. Ja, aber ich dachte mir, gut, ich nehme ein Geschenk mit, aber ich mache das jetzt natürlich nicht so uncool, so von wegen so, ha ha, schön dich zu sehen, hier hast du ein Geschenk. Ich hatte das Geschenk in meiner Tasche, habe erst mal nichts gesagt. Für die ersten zwei Stunden des Dates habe ich kein Wort gesagt. Und hat es überall Asche. Stichwort Hochstatus. Erst mal kein Wort sagen, lass sie erst mal reden. Die Schleife schaut offensichtlich aus deiner Jeans raus. Briefstatus. Bring den Ball mal ins Rollen. Und irgendwie erzählt sie so, ja, ja, ja, bla bla bla. Und dann so von wegen, jetzt im Sinne von und erwähnt dann irgendwann, wie Frauen halt so reden.
Blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, mit Pferde, Blumen, Pferde.
Und irgendwann meinte sie dann so, ja, ja, und dann hatte ich ihr Geburtstag und sie und dann auf jeden Fall habe ich... Und ich so, Moment.
Ich weiss. Und irgendwann meinte sie dann so, ja, ja, und dann hatte ich ja Geburtstag und sie und dann auf jeden Fall habe ich... Und ich so, Moment.
Kurzer Moment. Ich weiss.
Darauf warte ich seit zwei Stunden.
Und ich so, du hattest Geburtstag?
Ja, alles Gutes zum Geburtstag.
Bäm, hier ist ein Geschenk.
Nice, nice.
Oh ja.
Ja. Geschenk! Nice, nice, oh ja. Ja, yeah, nice, yeah, delivered, ja, und sie auch so, what, also wirklich so, krass, nicht schlecht, also da muss, also jetzt mal, so, Date ist ja oft so ein bisschen so, ja, ja, man tut, oder man tut, aber manchmal gibt's am Ende so, krass, nicht schlecht. Das war nicht schlecht. Und dann ist ja leider nur ein analoges Foto mit Finger drauf. Also es hat gut funktioniert, aber jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich als neugierige kleine Detektive. Warum ist daraus nichts geworden? Nee, es ist überhaupt nichts daraus geworden, keine Angst. Ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich, was war das für ein Geschenk? Und das Geschenk war ein, ein eingerahmtes Foto, das sich entwickelt haben lasse. Vor allem Tinder-Profil, was? Und jetzt fragt euch wahrscheinlich, welches Foto? Ja, das fragen wir uns.
Jetzt passt auf, ich zeige euch das Foto.
Oh, geil!
Moment! Okay, Achtung!
Hier kommt das Foto.
Er muss kurz an den Rechner, gerade auch das Podcast-Ophologe gehen.
Das Foto kommt in drei, zwei ja und deswegen ist es nichts geworden aus uns beiden das bitte doch mal im auszeiger ist es auch im bild wir haben genug Aufgebaut, Achtung, hier kommt das Foto in drei, zwei, eins. Ja, viel Fragezeichen im Raum, viele Fragezeichen im Raum. Was ist das?
Ja, und dafür kommt ihr zur Live-Podcast. Was ist das?
Ja, und dafür kommt ihr zur Live-Podcast-Show, damit ihr dieses Bild seht.
Ey, vor allem geil für unsere Podcast-Hörer, mal kurz im Ernst.
Also ihr seht ein süsses Kind.
So, jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich, what?
Ja, ich glaube vor allem, dass du Tinder nicht ganz verstanden hast. Und dieses süße Kind bin ich. Das sagtet ihr euch vielleicht schon. Und das war das eingerahmte Foto, das ich ihr geschenkt habe. Von mir... Wie weird ist das denn? Von mir als Kind. Du kannst doch einem... Okay, ich bin nicht Experte auf diesem Gebiet, okay? Dünnes Eis, wer im Glashaus sitzt, aber hey, ich würde sagen, man schenkt einer Frau auf dem ersten Date nicht ein Foto, eingerahmt, von sich selbst, auch noch als Kind mit einem muierden Hasen da drauf. Also der Hase ist das Problem. Das ist nicht nur ein Hase, Herr Tietze, das ist ein Evoli. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Das war das Evoli-Kuscheltier, das ich als Kind besessen habe. Und dieses Bild habe ich ihr geschenkt zum ersten Date. Das ist total weird. Warum denn? Diese Verwirrung im Raum, diese greifbare Verwirrung. Vor allem, ich finde es war eine coole Aktion, die aber hinten raus so, what? Ich würde behaupten, angenommen du merkst schon, ihr matcht euch und ihr habt euch verabredet, meinetwegen, und dann merkt ihr so, es funktioniert nicht so richtig und ich will sie irgendwie wieder loswerden und dann ist das die perfekte Taktik. Ja, ich hatte zwei Geschenke dabei. Einfach so eine. Ja, genau, man weiß nicht wie es läuft. Ein Handy. Und ich sag mal so, es gibt ja so einen gewissen Disconnect zwischen Online-Welt und echter Welt. Erwürgst du das Evo-Liga? Es ist ein sehr strammer Griff. Zu stramm. Ich erkenne einen zu strammen Griff, wenn ich einen sehe. Vielleicht wollte ich auch ein bisschen verdecken, dass ich dem davor den Kopf abgerissen habe. Der Wut, dass es nicht so läuft mit Frauen, verdammt nochmal. Und zwar hatten wir in der Konversation, die zu dem Tinder-Date hingeführt hat, das häufiger den ein oder anderen Pokémon-Gag gemacht. Und ich dachte mir, okay, sie ist eine Frau von Klasse, ich habe genau das richtige Bild für diesen Anlass. Ich als Kind mit Pokémon kuscheltiere. Und das ist so ein Punkt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber wenn man mit online... Tschüss, das ist nicht so laut. Weil du das Mikrofon zum ersten Mal nah an deinem Mund hält. Weil du es zum ersten Mal benutzt wie ein richtiger Mensch. Wenn man so online mit jemandem schreibt, irgendwie so, man versteht sich gut und dann trifft man sich und dann merkt man so, es ist ganz anders. So komplett anders und das ist oft so und weil, ich weiß nicht warum, aber es ist so, man denkt immer so, also ich dachte immer so, okay, ich bin genau der Mensch, so wie ich auch schreibe, so Pokemon und so, hier ein paar Gags und so, aber sie anscheinend nicht, sie meinte das vielleicht eher so ironisch oder so. Aber ganz bezart so, es ist wirklich interessant, wie man mit anderen Leuten schreibt, vor allem mit anderen Kulturen auch, und es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch spanische Freunde hat, aber spanische Freunde, also wenn man, ich hab dann manchmal einen Witz gemacht, so auf Englisch, weil spanisch heisst nicht mehr, aber so einen Witz auf Englisch und dann kommt zurück, ja, ja, ja, ja. Und man denkt so, ja, okay, dann lasse ich's halt einfach und dann der nächste Gag und wieder, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Bis ich verstanden habe, dass es ha ha ha ha ist, weil die das so aussprechen, ha ha ha ha, was, ein weirdes Lachen, aber sie meinen, sie haben den Gag verstanden und es ist wie ein Hahahaha zu schreiben. Lachen in Spanisch. Aber das war wirklich weird. Ja, ja. Ja, ja, du und deinem Gagster. Ja,. Dass es nicht so funktioniert hat, aber
ich sag mal, was schenkt man denn in so einer Situation,
einer Person, die man nicht kann? Ich denke mir immer so, es gibt so zwei
Möglichkeiten. Entweder man spielt sicher
oder man geht all in. Und ich bin jemand,
ich gehe immer direkt all in.
Ich denke mir so, natürlich kannst du jetzt, keine Ahnung,
eine Packung Toffee-Fischi,
keine Ahnung. Ist auch schon sehr all in.
Was Unverfängliches irgendwie.
Oder man sagt halt, nee, weißt du, ich schenke dir ein Kinderfoto von mir. Aber, also ungefähr so wie ihr jetzt schaut, war auch der Blick von dem Typen, der das Bild entwickelt hat. Wollt ein Foto entwickeln. So, jetzt können wir das Foto aber auch wieder... Ja, zeig mal mehr Fotos von dir. Zeig mal den Desktop. Kann jemand den Desktop sehen? Auf gar keinen Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall. Nein. Habt ihr bemerkt, dass am Anfang, als wir noch nicht auf der Bühne waren, plötzlich der Bildschirmschoner angegangen ist? Und wir haben einen Tweet gelesen, wo wir plötzlich diese Bühne sehen und nicht mehr das Podcast-Ufo-Logo, sondern den Bildschirmschoner, wo Florentins MacBook Pro steht und so langsam durchspielt. Aber glaubst du das auch bei der AC-DC-Bühnenshow? Wenn die lange nicht, dann steht da irgendwie so Mr AC-DCs MacBook oder so. MacBook Air, die haben bestimmt MacBook Airs, die sind so leicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Musik, ich habe wirklich keinen Plan, gar nicht. Überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, der Gitarrist von ACDC, der ist ja sehr cool, Angus Young, und der ist hingefallen auf der Bühne, weil er über Kabel gestolpert ist. Haha, kann auch normalen Menschen passieren. Der ist cool und gefallen trotzdem, aber er hat seine Stärke von sich gemacht. Er hat nämlich dann seitdem immer Soli auf dem Rücken liegend gespielt auf der Bühne, um zu kaschieren, dass er immer umfällt, weil er über Kabel läuft.
Auch unter Schmerz schreien, das war dann so sein Stil.
Haha, Alkohol.
Der Mauszeiger.
Der Mauszeiger nervt, sorry.
Ne, tu ihn in die Mitte, tu ihn in die Mitte jetzt.
Nein, nein, wer reinruft, wird bestraft. Tu ihn in die Mitte, tu ihn in die Mitte jetzt! Nein, nein, wer reinruft, wird bestraft. Tu ihn in die Mitte, tu ihn in die, nein, stopp, nein, nein, hör auf jetzt! So, das hast du jetzt davon. Mobbing! Der Applaus war für Mobbing. Ich habe eine App erfunden. Du hast eine Leiter erfunden? Was ist denn mit deinem Gehör los? Ich habe eine App erfunden. Ach so, ich war schon so, boah, eine neue Leiter, Alter, wie geht das denn? Und wir brauchen mal kurz jemanden auf der Bühne, der gerade, und es wird ein bisschen privat, wir stellen Fragen, die ihr vielleicht nicht beantworten wollt von dem Publikum, vor allem vom Live-Publikum. Hast du Tinder entdeckt? Bitte? Willst du Tinder erfinden? Ich will Tinder erfinden. Wir brauchen jemanden, der gerade eine Krankheit hat und er nicht weiß, was es ist. Oder so ein Husten oder halt irgendwie so was, was man so eine leichte Form von irgendwas ist gerade anders und ich weiss nicht was es ist.
Ja, okay, cool. Nicht nur, dass generell niemand Bock hat auf die Bühne zu gehen, weil vor allem kein Bock krank auf die Bühne zu gehen. Nee, aber jetzt so ein kleines Symptom, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt nicht schlimm, das ist auch nicht peinlich, aber so ein, ja komm, dann komm du mal auf die Bühne. Ich weiss nicht wo, ich weiss nicht wie, ob das hier...
Hey, eine...
Stefan, hallo. Bist ein bisschen erkältet, okay. Ist nicht so schlimm. Alles gut. So, und zwar erinnert ihr euch vielleicht, pass auf, also es hätte spannender werden können, wenn jetzt jemand irgendwie, weiß nicht, so eine Nervenkrankheit hat oder so. Aber pass mal auf. Und zwar habe ich damals folgende App erfunden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich noch erinnere, die Hardcore-Pufo-Fans werden es wissen. Ich habe gesagt, sowas wie der Akinator, also sozusagen so ein Wer bin ich, nur für Symptome. Und zwar fragt er dich aus, was hast du und du musst es eingeben und er sagt dir die Krankheit. Weil genau so funktioniert der Akinator, du musst sagen, an wen du denkst und er stellt dir Fragen und er findet heraus, an was du denkst, ergo, was du für eine Krankheit hast. Und diese App wurde jetzt exakt so entwickelt, multimillion, milliard, weiß ich nicht, wie man das nennt, aber sehr viel Geld verdient. Von Bayer. Von Bayer wirklich, ja. Und jetzt gibt es diese App und ich will es mit dir ausprobieren, okay? Also, die erste Frage. Ich bin gespannt, was gleich von der Krankheit rauskommt. Okay, die erste Frage ist, Stefan, um wen geht es? Jemand anderen. Bitte ausprobieren. Personen hinzufügen. Wie ist ihr Name? Carla. Carla. Ich weiss nicht, ob das irgendwo hinführt, aber vielleicht... So ist Carla männlich oder weiblich? Vollidiot, weiblich. Wann wurde Carla geboren, warum ist es... Du musst es aber sagen, wann du geboren wusst. Ich weiss nicht, warum das sehr interessant ist. Du kannst es vielleicht... Du kannst es auch ohne Mikrofon sagen. Du kannst es aber ein... Was? Pinn-Nummer von Carla. Bankleitzahl. Ey, aus eigener Erfahrung sag jetzt nichts mehr. Wie viele Nullen hast du im Pinn? Nur. Jetzt wird es ja persönlich. Ist sie schwanger? Sorry, muss gestellt werden? Hoffentlich nicht. Kannst du auch, ich bin nicht sicher sagen. Raucht sie regelmäßig? Ja, nein, das möchte ich nicht sagen. Was andere Frage, was bedeutet das? Warum sind sie gekommen, wenn sie nichts beantworten möchten? Genial. Wir wollen schon wissen, was das bedeutet, oder? Sie hat keine Asche im Arzt. Raucht sie regelmäßig? Nein, du siehst nicht, als ob du rauchst. Du rauchst nicht, oder? Menschenkenntnis Stefan. Sehr gut. Hat sie eine Vorgeschichte mit erhöhtem Blutdruck? Ja, nein, ich bin nicht sicher. Was bedeutet das? App verlassen. App verlassen. Steht nicht so aus, weil. Hast du Blutdruck? Hab ich? Ich weiß auch nicht genau, aber vor allem hast du... Hast du Blutdruck? Nein, das war...
Hast du eine Geschichte von Blutdruck?
Es wird jetzt, sorry, es wird ein bisschen persönlich, ich weiss nicht.
Hat sie Diabetes?
Nein.
Es ist eh Krebs.
Ja.
So.
Wir alle wissen's.
Jetzt, was beschäftigt dich am meisten? Gib ein Symptom.
So, jetzt musst du sagen...
Wird es jemals fliegende Autos geben?
Was beschäftigt dich am meisten als Krankheit jetzt gerade? Was funktioniert nicht in deinem Körper? Wo sagst du, hier ist Schluss, hier muss ich wieder gesund werden? Schleim. Gut. Ist okay, musst du nicht traurig sein. Das ist ein guter Amt-Wort. Das ist ein guter Amt-Wort. Das ist ein guter Amt-Wort. Das ist ein guter Amt-Wort. Das ist ein guter Amt-Wort. Vermehrt Schleim im Rachen, nicht essbare Substanzen essen. Ob einen das beschäftigt, Klobus im Hals, Schleim im Stuhl, Husten, laufende Nase, sorry, trockene Scheide, Blutung im Mund. Wir sind alle erwachsen, wir sind alle erwachsen. Die nächste Frage ist, wie auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wie sehr bereuen Sie, auf die Bühne gekommen zu sein? Das kommt gleich. Vermehrt Schleim im Rachen wahrscheinlich dann, ne? Ja. So, wie lange beschäftigt Sie diese Beschwerde? Kürzer als einen Tag? Einen Tag bis eine Woche, länger als ein Jahr. Eine Woche. Tag bis eine Woche. Eine Woche. Hat Sie weitere Beschwerden? Gliederschmerzen. Okay. Niemand lacht. So gut wie tot. Gliederschmerzen. Allgemeine Muskelschmerzen. Wie lange hat sie die Parazidebeschwerden? Kürzer, auch eine Woche, ne? Ja. Hat sie weitere Beschwerden? Nein. Hat sie eine laufende Nase? Ja. Yes. Okay. Wie würdest du das Aussehen ihres Nasenausflusses am besten beschreiben? Die Frage haben wir uns alle schon mal gestellt. Gibt es da Vergleichsbilder oder sowas? Es gibt nur klar, gelb, grün oder braun, krustig, wow, wow, oder ich weiss nicht. Krustiger Ausfluss. Wie geht das? Ist das so shotgun-mässig? Ja, ja. Ja, Carla, welche Form hat dein Ausfluss? Klar, gelbgrün... Wird es jetzt persönlich langsam. Ja, und es geht auch schlimmer. Klar, gelbgrün oder braun, krustig, ich weiss nicht. Ich weiss nicht. Ich hab's mir noch nicht genau angeschaut, sag ich mal. Verspürt sie einen Juckreiz in ihrer Nase? Ja. Ja, dieser verdammte Juckreiz. Ist die Rache ein aussergewöhnlich geröteter? Ja, nein, ich weiß nicht, was bedeutet das? Wir wissen nicht, was das bedeutet. Welche Farbe hat der Rache normalerweise? Welche Farbe hat der Rache im Allgemeinen? Es steht hier ein ungewöhnlich geröteter Rachen, er kann wesentlich geröteter als das umliegende Gewebe in der Mundhöhle sein.
Möchte ich nicht beantworten, wissen wir nicht.
Ich schaue selten in meinen Rachen.
Weird, weird.
Packt die Hypnose-App aus.
Ist Ihre Nasenschleimhaut besonders gerötet? Ich hab gerade auf dem Fortschrittspike umgeguckt. Warte, nehmt euch nichts mehr vor. Die nächsten Wochen. Ist Ihre Nasen-Schleimhaut besonders gerötet? Ich glaube nicht. Führt der Gag wohin? Nein. Hat sie Husten? Hat sie schon? Hat sie ein bisschen Husten? Ja, schon. Kleiner Tipp von mir, ich glaube, sie hat eine Erkältung. Nee. Hey, wir wollen das den Fachmann machen lassen. Hustet sie Schleim aus? Ja, ja, ja, das kenne ich. Jetzt ist es auch schon egal. Schau mal. Hat sie blutigen Husten beim Auge? Oh Gott. Nee, ne? Dann wärst doch nicht heute Abend hier. Es haben nämlich auch ein paar Leute geschrieben, dass heute Abend... Wohl am letzten Abend hier. Ja, letzter Abend hier. Viele haben geschrieben, dass sie krank geworden sind, deswegen heute nicht da sind. Deswegen würde ich sagen, wenn du einen blutigen Auswurf hättest, wär's heute nicht hier. Nein. Okay, letzte Frage. Wie haben sich ihre Beschwerden verändert? Sie haben sich verschlechtert, sie haben sich verbessert, sie sind unverändert. Verschlechtert. Oh, shit. Danke, Stefan. Ja, gern. Bitte, Stefan. Ich habe einen Bericht zusammengestellt, der mögliche Ursache für Ihre Beschwerden auflistet. Okay. Bitte denkt daran, dass dies keine medizinische Diagnose ist. Im Zweifelsfall ist es das Beste, die Meinung eines A-S-S-E-Z-E-Z-Hol. Das sagst du mir jetzt, nach einer halben Stunde lang Test, Erkältung. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Carla, sehr gut. Vielen Dank. Ciao. Carla hat eine Erkältung. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, wie gut. Wow, wie weit die Technik heute, ne? Das ist unfassbar. Wahnsinn! Personen mit ähnlichen Symptomen können sie normalerweise selbst behandeln. Danke. Sie sind schlecht? Nicht schlecht. Erkältung, acht von zehn Personen mit den gleichen Symptomen haben diese Erkrankung. So, ich würde sagen, wir machen noch zwei, oder? Wer hat Bock, wer kommt auf die Bühne? Fantastisch. Aber ohne Scheiss, jetzt im haus sind juristen aus ja guck mal so jurist braucht sich nach vorne kommen ist keine krankheit aber aber aber angenommen also ich habe es ja vor ein paar monaten in diesem podcast gesagt das heißt es gibt ein ein beglaubigtes, und ihr seid alle Zeugen, es gibt einen Ausschnitt, wo ich das sage. Das ist rechtens. Also das ist ja so eine Art Patent. Worum geht es? Habt ihr verstanden, worum es geht? Naja, also der Typ hat mir meine App geklaut, dieser Schweinepriester. Ach so. So sehr wirklich sauer auf den, der sich Schweinepriester nennen.
Aber der hat einfach meine App geklaut jetzt und der macht alles Geld mit.
So, das ist offensichtlich die Idee von uns.
Kann man da jetzt was machen? Ruf mal ja oder nein.
Nee, die Idee an sich ist nicht schützenswürdig.
Die Idee an sich ist, das rufen alle gleichzeitig, haben gerade ein Rufen, die Idee an sich ist nicht schützenswürdig.
What? Das ist doch die Mega-Idee.
Jede Idee ist schützenswürdig. Okay? Das lernt man nicht im Studium, das lernt man im Leben. Okay. Hat Spaß gemacht heute Abend, oder? Findest du nicht auch? Ja, mir schon. Auf jeden Fall. Mir hat es auch Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, manche Leute aus Publikum nicht, vor allem die, die unsere ganze Krankheitshistorie uns vorbeten mussten. Ja, lieben gruselte an alle, die gerade so ein bisschen von Carla wegrücken, einfach die ganze Zeit, einfach so fliehend. Und da hat sich doch noch ein Moshpit gebildet. Hey, jetzt auch viel Spaß bei der Death of Wall, Wall of Death, ach fuck you, einfach jetzt kein Schluss noch mal. Eine Sache möchte ich aufklären, falls sich jetzt die Zuschauer, die Hörer die ganze Zeit fragen, was war da los.
Als Carla auf die Bühne gekommen ist, habe ich ihr meine Hand zum Handschlag angeboten und sie hat mir eiskalt den Rücken zugewendet.
Deswegen wurde da gelacht, aber auch an der Stelle nochmal, Carla, ich brauche dich nicht.
Okay? Hast du eine Ahnung, wie viele Kinderfotos von mir ich noch habe ich kann jede haben die ich will jede ganz recht jede jede vielen dank für diesen applaus vielen dank Florentin dankeschön Einen fantastischen Abend. Ja, das war's, das war unsere Köln-Lifestand, das war somit unsere erste Tour. Das war die erste Mal nur Köln und Berlin Tour 2018. Wir haben erst mal nur Köln und Berlin gemacht und wir schauen mal, wie es war da. Es war anstrengend, nervenaufreibend, hat aber auch Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank fürs Kommen, Ihr könnt euch weiterhin natürlich gerne an unserem Merch-Shop begeistern und
dort reichlich einkaufen. Es gibt auch
noch ein paar, habe ich gehört, ein paar limitierte
Poster von guter Arbeit. Ja, wo
alle Skripte drauf sind. Alle Skripte, ganz klein
abgedruckt. Alle Skripte, limitierte Fassung,
holt euch das auf jeden Fall. Ansonsten
sind wir auch noch in der Gegend und
auf jeden Fall vielen Dank fürs Rumkommen,
vielen Dank fürs Hören. Macht's gut, schönen Abend noch
heute rein, das war das Podcast UV,
macht's gut, ciao!
Dankeschön!
Vielen Dank, war echt cool. Applaus